being 10 o'clock we can start whoever
hold that down good morning thank you uh
I'm uh Bill Cass commissioner of the
Department of Transportation so
um happy to be here to brief uh
committee and give kind of an overview
uh General high-level overview of the
department uh for General understanding
um with me is Dave rodrigue he's the
assistant commissioner we do have a
third seat for uh the Deputy
Commissioner if he shows up he's
testifying at a at another bill
um but if he does he'll he'll join us if
not um Dave and I will cover it so Andre
Briere
as a Deputy Commissioner
so so with that
um I'll just flip you through the the
slides that we have so on the on the
first page is um the mission and purpose
statement for the dot so our mission is
transportation Excellence to enhance the
quality of life in in New Hampshire uh
transportation is vital for uh the state
and um especially in the uh Economic
Development so our our purpose is always
to provide high quality transportation
system and services
that are safe well-maintained efficient
reliable and meet the needs of New
so on the second
if you skip the introduction one so the
second the second um
slide is an overview of the Department's
organizational structure uh I introduce
myself I'm the commissioner and we have
two uh other Commissioners Dave the
assistant commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner Andre Brier who isn't here
but we oversee five divisions so the
department is
um
organized into five to five divisions
Dave is the assistant commissioner and
chief engineer kind of oversees the
operations uh and project development
side of the house so that's all of the
projects that that we do and all of the
operations of the day-to-day maintenance
of the of the system and uh he'll give
you a little bit more detail on that
on the other side of the house the
Deputy Commissioner kind of oversees
um more of the administrative
administrative functions a division of
finance
policy and administration as well as the
um
uh Aeronautics Rail and Tron Aeronautics
Rail and Transit the non-highway type of
uh Transportation aspects that we
oversee
so on the next slide just to give some
scope and breadth as a overview of
um you know some keep acts about the
D.O.T we have a
um we have about 1650 permanent
positions
um that's not that many employees those
are positions because we are dealing
with uh some vacancy rates which I'll
um discuss later with if we get into
some of the challenges that the
department is facing
there are
2159 State bridges that uh that we
maintain
uh the state red list that's the number
of structurally deficient Bridges
um of that 2159 114 are red listed or
structurally deficient and we have been
working to drive that number down
in addition to the um
2160 state state Bridges
um there are around 1700 Municipal
bridges in this in the state those are
bridges owned
um by the municipalities but the dot is
responsible for uh ensuring their safety
so we inspect all of the municipal
Bridges and all of the state bridges on
our goal our delivery is to try to
inspect every bridge in the state at
least once every two years
to make sure that there's a redless
Bridges uh get get more eyes on them
they were viewed usually once every six
months to make sure that their condition
is stained
so we oversee about 4 600 Centerline
miles of roadway
um and on that we maintain uh over a
hundred thousand highway signs we try to
stripe uh every Road in the state once a
year that's our goal it means about 68
million feet of striping
as well as 440 traffic signs 550 beacons
we oversee uh 194 miles of active
state-owned Rail lines
25 publicly accessible airports and 11
local public transit systems that fall
under our domain or at least the
administration and the funding that
passes through dot to help support those
services
so that's just a quick
um
some factoids that give the scope and
breadth of our oversight on in the state
um
on the
on the fifth page I guess is a budget
overview it gives a quick very high
level snapshot of what rfy
2022 actual expenditures were so
um almost 600 million dollars of actual
expenditures
and we try to organize our budget and
talk about it and and two main
um two main pieces two main aspects uh
the municipal Aid and construction part
of the budget
um a little over 300 million dollars
is a lot of the uh pass-through money
money that comes through the dot two
cities and towns and a big part of that
is also the federal dollars that come to
support
um the highway program the construction
program that we put out
the other piece of the budget is
um you know what a lot of the focus is
uh this year with the budget is the
operating uh budget which
um is all the men and women that um make
up the dot and all the uh materials and
supplies and things that we use in
maintaining the roads and that's around
200 and a little under 300 million
dollars about 282 million in FY 22
expenditures so
um one of the things for division two uh
and I think we'll get into more detail
um it's a rather complicated budget
because we deal with a lot of different
funding sources and the and the
breakdown of our over overall budget is
is
um
is uh listed there at the bottom overall
um about 40 federal funds uh 28 Highway
funds about 20 Turnpike funds 13 other
other interagency type of funds and
point two percent General funds so we
have very little
um
drawer on the general fund and uh you
know when you look at those two pieces
of the budget uh up there so the
municipal Aid and construction the
majority of that is the federal funding
that goes in to support the construction
program on the operating side of the of
that half of the budget the majority of
that becomes the highway fund that
supports
um so with that
um and if there are any questions along
the way please stop and ask and we can
get it and
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for taking
my question now we've just gone through
the pandemic
um I've noticed that traffic is a lot
heavier
so just driving to Boston is awful now
um how are things seeming because I know
when
um the former commissioner came in and
testified she had talked about what we
did well it was virtually
um what we didn't know was gonna if cars
were gonna come back the way they were
or we're going to work more virtually
what are you seeing
right um where we're still seeing that
even though traffic has rebounded
um it has not
um come back to pre-pandemic levels so
particularly on the turnpike system
um we monitor transactions and revenue
through through the um through the tolls
every day so we have a good history and
we've continued to compare
um traffic volumes to the pre-pandemic
levels and we've seen it kind of rebound
back but it's run still about
uh between seven and nine percent below
what it was in 2019.
um so it and that is a a little bit of
an impact on the revenue stream
um in the in the turnpike fund and
that's you know mainly you know the
monitoring the the major highways you
know we have a permanent counter out on
I-93 and through the through the toll
plazas but it's pretty indicative I
think of the overall travel travel
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions there are two one of
them is I just want to make sure I
understand correctly when you say you're
responsible for the safety of the
municipal Bridges I understand that to
mean that you're responsible for
inspecting them and deciding if they are
safe it's the municipalities that then
have the burden of dealing with any
safety issues as needed am I
understanding that correctly yes that's
correct we do do the inspections and we
work with the towns if there are any
deficiencies
um
so we we do all the inspections because
there is federal reporting for all
bridges and um for consistency's sake it
works out best having it come through
um through the state DOT so it's
consistent but we work if there are any
uh deficiencies load postings things
like that we work with the
municipalities to see that it is um
addressed we do have uh a small amount
of of state aid toward um of course
Municipal Bridges
I'm familiar with that again that kind
of goes with uh you know having been the
finance director of Windham we did have
a bridge that we had to get State
financing and you know we've gone
through all that process but I just
wanted to make sure that I understand
the state level process I don't want to
just look at it from a parochial point
of view and the 11 local public transit
systems can you give me idea of what our
responsibilities are towards them
because obviously I see the word local
and we are dealing with the state so I
just want to understand that balance
between how is the state responsible for
what part of the local uh you know
public transit systems yeah the majority
of our responsibility is the
administration of the of the funding so
we um we are the conduit for all of the
Federal Transit um
Administration funding that goes to
support those
local public transit agencies
thank you
um two things in the last round there
was some concern and it might have just
been pandemic related of what or if you
were getting federally
um is idea either those still concerns
do they still maintain or do you know
what you'll be getting from the federal
um yes yes well yes and no so uh I don't
I don't remember when the last uh
presentation and discussion was but um
before
um there was a lot of uncertainty before
the um iija the federal infrastructure
Act was was passed it was a year-to-year
continuing resolution and things like
that so though that's great on
uncertainty with the passage
um last year of the federal
infrastructure bill
um it was also the reauthorization bill
so we have a look ahead for five years
of of our um
of our formula funding
um that that comes to support the
highway program and I said yes and no
because as part of the infrastructure
bill in addition to the reauthorization
and our formula funding
um there are a number of uh competitive
discretionary Grant
um programs to go along and support
um
the overall infrastructure bill so
something like
you know 40 percent of the of the
funding of the money that that came with
that infrastructure bill
um is wrapped up in discretionary Grant
programs some are discretionary Grant
programs
um that that the state agencies can can
participate to go after several of them
are
programs that only municipalities or
other constituencies can can seek um
funding so I say uh yes and no because
there's no guarantees for those they are
competitive you have to go through a
Grant application process we do try to
take advantage of of those but it is not
a not a not a guarantee
yeah my other question then so we've got
a number of new people here is it
possible now you may get to this later
on but is it um could you quickly go
through what funds can be used for what
and what funds can't be used for
specific things that's always one of the
things we're looking at with in the
budget of certain funds are only can be
used only for this I think we hit some
of that as we go through some of the
um
divisions in a little more detail so
hopefully we'll head on hit on some of
that but as we get to the end if there
are more questions we can make sure we
take them up sure
so if this is helpful I was going to ask
Dave to go through a little bit more
detail on the divisions that he oversees
and I think he'll we will hit on some of
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is David rodrigue and
I am the assistant commissioner for DOT
as well as the D.O.T chief engineer so
as Bill explained I'm responsible
primarily for two divisions in the D.O.T
the division of project development in
the division of operations the division
of project development includes several
bureaus work to together to plan design
advertise oversee the construction of
our transportation system they take care
of our our right-of-way
um and they help us make sure that we're
environmentally compliant as as well so
then are a number of bureaus we have our
Bureau of Highway design that includes
our project managers as well as a
project design teams and a utilities
section
um that works as we design our projects
to coordinate with different utilities
uh use our right-of-way to
um transmit power communication and and
so forth we have our Bureau bridge
design that's responsible for Designing
uh bridges for doing projects to
preserve and maintain our bridges and
also for inspecting all of averages and
the municipal Bridges as as you had
pointed out our typical cycle is to
inspect the bridges every two years if
the bridges are on our red list which
means as Bill said they're structurally
deficient we look at those every six
months to make sure those continue to be
safe and we're on top of the condition
of those bridges because things can
change pretty quickly
um as they start to deteriorate we have
our Bureau of construction a bureau of
construction once projects are
advertised on a private contract
typically
um is the one who's doing the work in
our Bureau of construction oversees the
construction of the project they make
sure sure that the Project's built
according to plans they solve the
day-to-day issues that come up during a
construction project make sure the right
materials are used and and so forth we
have our Bureau of right-of-way who
purchases the land and the easements
that we need for our projects and also
keeps track of of what we already own
and how we how we own that land in that
property we have our Bureau of
environment that helps us with the
permitting of all of our projects make
sure as we construct them we're
constructing them in an environmentally
responsible way according to our permits
and then helps us on the operation side
as we're maintaining our infrastructure
to make sure we're doing that according
to environmental requirements as as well
um we have a bureau of planning and
Community Assistance that works with the
communities on municipally managed
projects and oversees some of the
federal funds and state funds that flow
to the communities and helps the
communities be successful in designing
advertising and constructing those
projects themselves they also handle a
mapping a GIS layers and some other
things as well and finally we have our
Bureau of materials and research in
materials and research is involved in
making sure that we specify the right
materials in our construction projects
and then make sure that the contract is
contractor is delivering those materials
that meet the specifications so that we
we get what we're paying for in our
projects it's a complex system of a lot
of a lot of people that work together to
get the job done right
thank you Mr chair
um we've heard a lot of angst around
construction of any kind
what are you experiencing are your costs
going up um due to the pandemic and
shoulders of supplies we hear it in
housing we hear it I know in my city
we're hearing about the increase overall
of costs of everything so what's the
impact on the state so Bill Bill will
touch on some of that later in the
presentation but I I would say off the
out off the the bat there's two major
things uh challenges we're facing in
that area right now the first is
inflation and in addition to inflation
meaning costs have have increased
significantly that that we we also have
a challenge just getting things
delivered so for the first time in in my
history on the operation side we we buy
equipment and the legislature realizing
how how poor our equipment was has
really taken care of us and funded our
equipment budget in the last biennium
bottom line we order equipment we wait
for a vendor to deliver it they say
you'll have it in nine months nine
months passes and they cancel the PO and
say we can't deliver it for that cost
previously to to before the pandemic
there was a list of people who wanted to
provide us equipment there was a list of
contractors who wanted to build job if
vendor a didn't deliver no problem
you're done we're going with them to be
that doesn't work that way anymore today
vendor B you go on their list and you
wait nine months for them and then they
may tell you that so we always like to
think that we have Choice
um we're seeing a a construction
atmosphere and a purchasing atmosphere
where we don't have the choice that we
would like to have or the control that
we would like to have because we don't
always have those B and C bidders of
vendors to back it up so that's one
Challenge and the other challenge that
is really stock for us is being able to
hire people
we have significant vacancy rate rates
again what do we do when we have a
vacancy rates in the past we lean on our
engineering consultants and we lean on a
private
um suppliers bottom line engineering
Consultants they're having a difficult
time hiring people they are not staffed
to deliver as we would like them to do
and contractors very much the same way
when we do a building
um project for one of our facilities the
building contract there's few bidders
Public Works Das can can fill you in on
this but there's very few bidders and
they have
um material delays very much the same
thing if you're waiting for a heating
system or or something
um you have to wait you may not get it
and the contractors are dealing with
they put in a bid and then prices
increase during uh the life of the the
contracts particularly if it's a
multi-year contract so it's a long
answer but I hope I get to what you were
looking for
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
being here and thank you for taking my
question uh levies how much involvement
do you have you got uh the kachiko which
runs underneath uh bridge on 153 and 75.
and we're having a tussle in our town
over that and I was wondering how much
involvement and what uh what you could
do about it because it does affect your
Bridges if the the river bottom isn't
taken care of properly
right so
um I don't know if Bill is is familiar
with that I think 75 and 153 I think
you're talking about Farmington and the
kachiko river and as that flows through
I'm not intimately familiar with the
bridge or the situation that you're
describing I know either I I don't know
if you mean like environmental
permitting or somebody that is reviewing
and maintaining
what they what they were doing is
putting the uh putting a dozer in the
river and just grooming the you know the
stone and making sure there was enough
uh Stone in the sidewalls to make sure
that it doesn't wash out
and I guess we're having trouble I
didn't know how much the state would get
involved or a civil engineer they say
there's a levy there there's a levy to
protect the town because it's I mean
it's called puddled off for a reason
okay and and that's and they said that
the levy is going down and but it but
they're having problems with putting a
dozer in the river I mean which we've
done for 50 years that I can remember
right so I mean that's it maybe we can
talk about this later but it's it's I
was curious to find out how much you get
involved with that sure not not very not
not not as much unless it does affect
our infrastructure we've worked with Des
on a couple of other similar projects
um not not similar but similar type of
issues we had a project
um uh where we had helped provide some
funding uh they did a river
stabilization on um I think it's a
suncooked South Cook River and an
evulsion that happened there it was
cutting back uh and uh somewhere down
the line could have threatened the route
four Bridge so we had worked with them
we could get into a lot of detail we
could probably talk after but I think we
we see
um
similar things like that as to whether
it be on the sea cow Seacoast or up
north things things that were done in in
the past uh in terms of getting in the
river and cleaning things out we see a
lot of aggregation
um in in the Riverbanks and uh you know
30 40 years ago we would have you know
probably gone in and and moved that that
stuff back but um
now it's much more letting the river
river environment take its course and
and dealing with things that they come
up with it but
I don't know if I I so we we get
involved with it in similar type of
things when it is a an issue for some of
our infrastructure but as far as the
overall management of a levy or or River
Bottom
um that would probably working with the
with the like Environmental Services
sure
yeah thank you can you give me some
guidance with regards to
um
enforcement and the red line Bridges
um in particular you know you know the
bridge I'm talking about but um yeah
where you've got bridges that are
redlined and why I'm bringing this up is
because I've had a couple people
um in the area of construction come to
me to say that
um they know based on their personal
experience and knowledge that um trucks
are going over that little Bridge we
have a big construction project in
Newcastle it's a large residence that
they're going over that bridge and they
says you know because of their
experience with construction they know
they're over the limit and
who's responsible for check what can you
do it's not like y'all are out there you
know checking that chief White is not
standing on the bridge and even if he
were what's he going to do so is there
any mechanism for enforcement of what
happens when you've got you know a red
line bridge that is you know in serious
shape and you've got trucks going over
it that are well over the limit
um I was just trying to come up with
scenarios and it's like you wait until
the bridge falls down and then give them
a fine so can you just talk give me a
narrative about how you deal with that
sort of a problem
yeah and I'll I'll let Dave uh chime in
a little bit more but but essentially
um
you know we we look at the structural
condition and we we post it and and I I
would say you know we always want to be
safe and I'm sure from an engineering
perspective there are factors of safety
in in those in those postings
um we have had similar examples
um where we
um
have had stronger concern and have had
targeted enforcement around certain
Bridge postings and things like that at
the end of the day it is the Department
of Safety State Police that has a um
uh weight enforcement unit
and that's that's for you know that's
for all legal loads as well to not
necessarily just the the posted Bridges
but um
um you know legal loads on all all
um on all roads and stuff and seeing
that trucks and things that are
um Meeting those legal loads I don't
know Dave if you've worked closer with
Department of Safety Troop G dude I I
would just add first of all thank you
for your concern because we share your
your concern an overloaded trucks do two
types of damage to the bridge obviously
the worst type of of damage is a bridge
failure that that we can never never see
and we do everything we we can to
protect against that but short of a
bridge failure overloaded trucks have an
incremental
um degradation of the condition of the
bridge so they may not make it fall down
but as they travel over it the cracks
get a little bigger they get a little
deeper the deflections are a little
further and a little more frequent and
they they accelerate rate the end of the
life of that that bridge one of the
reasons why for red listed Bridges we
look at them every six months to make
sure that we catch those things when it
comes to enforcement there there are
very specific laws about legal loads and
what is legal to go over the road in
Troop G
um from State Police is responsible to
enforce those with of course limited
resources and they can't be everywhere
all the time people ask me about the
bridge I said well when you go over the
so if you'd like uh oh I'm just gonna
ask Miss chair I I want to be sensitive
to time we can we can jump jump to some
specific items of Interest here or or
keep going it's up to you okay very good
then uh Dave continue thanks all right
very good so just wrapping up with the
project Development Division
um well they do all those individual
pieces one of their primary
responsibilities is preparing and
delivering the state's 10-year
Transportation Improvement plan and that
that 10-year plan is updated every two
years through a very formal process
where
um the gasset and the the dot will work
with the the gasic committee the
governors
um executive counselors and go around to
communities and have public hearing
things on what's in the 10-year plan and
take input into
what the communities in the regional
planning commissions would like to see
added to the 10-year plan and shift it
the word of caution that that goes along
with that is
everybody wants to be in the 10-year
plan the 10-year plan is fiscally
constrained there is not an unlimited
pot of money so projects coming into the
10-year plan typically push other
projects out of the 10-year plan we
talked about inflation and part of our
new federal
infrastructure legislation has provided
some increased funds that have helped us
to be able to to continue with projects
that are in the plan and paid the
difference for some of that inflation
but it doesn't leave a lot of extra
funds to to add additional projects
especially right now we the department
really rely on the regional planning
commissions to listen to the communities
and help us prioritize those Regional
needs and then of course the counselors
and at the end of the day the 10-year
plan we prepare a recommended 10-year
plan that then Works its way through the
legislature for approval and finally
goes to to the governor's desk for
approval the big caution on that process
again is it is fiscally constrained so
things that come in and move up
typically bump things out
all right uh thank you you keep
mentioning inflation what do you see as
inflation rate roughly uh
that you're seeing in your new projects
and whatever right
I I can get you that number we have a a
very specific inflation rate that is is
computed through our Bureau of
construction folks and I don't have that
with me Bill I don't know somewhat
anecdotally
um you know uh at the end of um
at the end of last season you know
through through the spring and summer
that's gas prices and everything's went
up we certainly saw
um
you know bid prices on contracts
um exceeding our our estimates by
um you know fifteen twenty percent so
that was kind of the running inflation
rate
um again a little anecdotally we have
more more detail I know and we will be
looking at it as a question as we look
at the update of the 10-year plan how
um conservative or realistic or uh you
know how conservative we want to be in
terms of
projecting escalation for all those
future future projects but yeah we were
seeing
um you know 20 or so
um increases in in construction costs uh
through last year I know when we've kind
of looked at looked at it over a little
bit longer period of time we do a um we
do a monitoring with the construction
costs index and going back to
um about three years right right around
the time of the pandemic and looking at
that longer period we've been seeing
around on 11
um
growth in the construction costs index
so
whether it continues to know at those of
the economic forecasts that we have to
right
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
follow-up to what you were just saying
do you have any color around how much of
that Spike was due to perceived risk and
how much was actual inflation because
obviously you know when the pandemic
started it wasn't clear if you could get
anything done and people had to hike up
the price because they were not sure if
they can get the materials and they were
you know
adding a risk premium to the contract do
you have any unders any any color to add
to how much of that may have been you
know a risk premium versus an actual
increase in the supplies and actual
costs I know it's a tough question I'm
just looking for anything you may have I
I I yeah I really don't I I don't the
one thing I I will say you know on on we
did see more of that risk based
um cost increase over longer term
contracts so if we had a if we had a one
season contract
um you know for a Paving project or
something like that I think the
inflation there was was was strictly in
inflation when we saw some of those
higher costs on a on a multi-year
contract I know from the feedback I
heard from the contractors the labor
market and some of that uncertainty
which I think gets to your um
risk was was factored in there but I
don't have a I don't have a sense of I
appreciate it and I know that it's a
really tough question but again any
information is useful so I appreciate
what you are able to provide thank you
and I would add a little bit more color
to that the the work that we do is very
fuel intensive and very steel steel
intensive so you look at the price of
fuel you look at the price of steel you
look at the price of Labor and you get
an idea of really what drives a lot of
um a little a little bit more
information
um on a 10-year plan we we deliver about
225 million dollars worth of federal
projects
um each year the 10-year plan projects
are primarily federally funded there are
some some programmatic State funds and
and there as well
um and a few other state funds in fiscal
year 22 we added 57 new construction
contracts in Iberia construction
provided oversight on 84 active
construction projects with a combined
total value of 750 million dollars worth
of work that they were overseeing and
um also in 22 we advertised 233 million
dollars worth of contracts
so that's the division of project
development shifting over to the
includes
um several bureaus that oversee the
operations and maintenance of our
transportation system so they're the
ones who uh plow in the snow fixing the
bridges washing the the bridges
maintaining the bridges and so forth so
I'll walk through quickly each of of
those bureaus we have the Bureau of
Highway Maintenance which is our largest
Bureau in operations and they have
spread around the state we have six
Highway Maintenance districts and we
have 87 Patrol sheds around the state
that are responsible for the roads
within their sections I always want to
explain 87 Patrol sections sounds like a
lot but when you think of of New
Hampshire and the number of towns and
and cities we have winds up to one
Patrol section covering about two and a
half to two and three quarter towns in
these these crews are made up of five to
to 12 people for some of our crews the
larger crews are the ones that take care
of our interstate system so it's really
not a lot when you think of five or six
people taking care of all the state
roads and two and a half or or so towns
um Highway Maintenance maintains uh the
the roads does the snow plow operations
they're the ones when we have
emergencies that you see out there
working 24 hours a day seven days a week
to get those roads opened back up just
as quick as possible so Emergency
Services can get to people and so that
um life can return to normal for folks
um they also manage our driveway
permitting process so if a business or a
homeowner wants to construct a new
driveway onto a state road they get a
permit through a Highway Maintenance
districts and part of that permit
process is to make sure that that
driveway is is safe and not that
driveway doesn't
um deteriorate the the efficiency and
the capacity of the roadway
um Beyond what's reasonable if it hasn't
impacts they work with the developers to
mitigate those those impacts
operations also includes the Bureau of
traffic traffic is responsible for a
roadway line striping for taking care of
our signs and traffic signals they're
also responsible for setting speed
limits interesting thing about Bureau of
traffic and when we talk about pavement
markings and speed limits
um so pavement markings it's passing
zones speed limits it's how high or low
um
one one way of looking how those issues
come up one way to explain it is most
people want the passing zone closed and
the speed limit lowered in front of
their home or property but everywhere
else they drive they want the speed
limit higher and they want as many
passing opportunities as as we can get
so there is a lot of tension in that
Bureau as as they work to take care of
um both the the local people's needs but
as as the state DOT a real
responsibility is to make sure that
everybody's Transportation Needs A
Satisfied and that includes folks who
need to to get from the southern part of
our state to the northern part of the
state or the east to west and they can't
do that efficiently at 30 or 25 or 20
miles an hour the whole way so a little
bit of tension then Bridgeman
maintenance we have 12 Bridge
maintenance Crews Bridge maintenance one
of those Crews takes care of the
Portsmouth and Newcastle with Bridges
and and so forth
um and also the crews Statewide
um do bridge maintenance they do bridge
preservation projects
um and help to to keep those bridges
serviceable they also respond to
emergencies and help things going we've
done a lot of work on Asset Management
um over the last 10 plus plus years and
one of the things we've we've really
learned is maintenance and preservation
is the cheapest way to drive a a low
asset life cycle when it comes to
bridges that means washing the salt off
the bridges in the spring we still don't
get to do that to every bridge every
year although we try those local cost
things that require people in labor pay
off in the long run they're very
difficult when you're trying to manage
that bottom line of the budget every
every year
we have our Bureau of Mechanical
Services we have a Statewide garage here
and and Concord state-of-the-art
facility and we have six
um garages around the state a mechanical
fleet has a replacement value of about
110 million dollars very significant if
you think an average piece of equipment
lasts 10 years you do the math we should
be putting in 11 million dollars a year
to keep that going and that Fleet is
primarily not exclusively but primarily
the plow trucks and the spreaders and
the plow trucks and so forth that you
see out there on the road during the
winter
we have a fuel distribution section a
field distribution folks have 92 sites
across the state for that that provides
fuel for State local and some non-profit
groups
um to purchase fuel 24 7 at those
facilities we also have our Bureau of
Transportation Systems management and
operations
um that's a an evolving field
um and that is all about making sure
that we help let drivers know what's
going on on the roadway Network so that
they can make decisions that that are
best for them so tismo they control the
the cameras they controlled the message
boards that are out there our road
weather information systems and they
have traveler Information Systems as
well that that provide people
information that helps us with
efficiency it's also a huge help when it
comes to safety so if an accident for
instance if an accident occurs on an
interstate and traffic starts to to back
up studies show as that cue backs up
secondary accidents often occur and are
often sometimes worse than the initial
incident so having first of all being
able to recognize that there's an
accident there quickly and then provide
motorists approaching that that accident
the information that the stop Traffic
Ahead makes for a safer Network and when
we provide that with delay information
it also helps people choose other routes
so they don't miss their flight or their
important appointment
what's up
thank you Mr chair first I didn't write
down the original the names when I uh
you know you guys introduced yourselves
and I noticed that the website has the
commissioner and the deputy
Commissioners names but you are
Anonymous would you be able to just tell
me your name one more time it's like
um I was appointed and confirmed in
December so I'm it's nothing against me
I'll be there I don't want to get to the
department politics you know it's all
good but just a quick clarification a
couple of clarification questions you
said six garages the handout says seven
I just don't know which number is I'm
sorry we have the Central Garage in
Concord and then we have six uh around
the satellite thank you and you were
saying that the fleet uh you know is has
about the 10-year life cycle is that
what you see operationally or is that
more of a accounting uh you know
depreciation schedule that we use can
you comment on what how what life do you
get out of the you know say plow drugs
which obviously have a lot of views yes
so
average we use that or I use that number
of 10 years for simple math to to get
the investment
um cars have a a useful life of five or
six years or 150 000 miles
um a lot of our trucks have a projected
life of 20 12 years
um or again uh about 150
000 miles we also have our parameters
that go on that
um those life cycles include selling
that asset when there's still a value to
it and then putting that money back into
the the fleet so we actually they're
they're a state dots that turn over
their vehicles every two years and they
find that to be most efficient
um because they sell them while they're
still value in them
um when New Hampshire we're never going
to to turn over our vehicles every every
two years but we do need to to
um turn them over at the thresholds that
we check set to be more efficient that
being said there's always a good
percentage of the fleet that's beyond
those those parameters thank you I
appreciate it and really it's new
information and it's very good and the
last question is it does it's not a huge
question but frankly I was just going to
say that when we talk about you know
anticipating an accident and traffic and
whatnot personally I use Waze and it
does a darn good job of telling me
what's ahead and uh you know are we
working in any way with such apps I'm
not I don't want to focus on one of them
but on those types of apps is there any
effort to integrate or feed data or you
know pull data from them and try to
benefit from some of the free work
because Waze makes a living by getting
users to do all the work of providing
that information and just Aggregates it
is that something we're trying to take
advantage of one way or the other
we do we integrate with ways so there
there's a couple parts of of traveler
information one is determining when and
where an incident occurs the other is
processing what actually is happening
and then the third is what's the right
information dissemination to the public
so with an app-like ways our system
actually sends them information that we
have in that traveler information system
not only provides information that we
learn ourselves it also allows the users
to click a a box in to show the ways
incidents on that travel or information
uh thank you Mr chairman uh
the uh are you having trouble finding
contractors for snow plowing and things
like that and the cost I mean to stay
within you know your it's hard to stay
within a budget when you get a 20
inflation and also for the bridge
construction I noticed you pulled one of
your rfps for uh 93 I believe
Londonderry because you couldn't get a
bid which was within uh what you
expected to pay
right so
all right so so your first question I'm
sorry final plow drivers yeah plow
drivers yes
yes
we absolutely are so we have a long
history of using contract rental plow
drivers so we have the ability through
through the laws and the rules that of
Department of administrative services to
sign up by the hour plow trucks with
with operators
um we've done quite well with that over
the years and in fact when we're staffed
right we're about 60 percent contract
plow drivers and about 40 percent dot
plow drivers and trucks recent years we
are much closer to 50 50 where it's 50
percent Dot and 50 contract plow drivers
for several reasons the the first is a
lot of those plow drivers used to get
our old trucks when we turned them over
regularly and for for years we under
invested and roughly and then we took
advantage of Volkswagen funds which was
great to help us at least get a couple
trucks but we had to to destroy those
trucks so they did not feed that market
that's that's one issue the the second
issue is we plow with one shift so when
that storm starts not before when it
starts we call our cruise in to begin to
plow the snow that same crew is there
till the storm ends and we go around and
clean up our
um contract rental trucks are an
important part of the people who need to
be with us from start to finish the
truth is there's fewer and fewer people
who want to to do that today and who can
structure their lives so that they they
can do that today and then finally they
they face the same pressures we do with
with the labor market and we have owners
tell us we have three or four trucks I
can only put one on because I only have
one one driver
um so if I had more drivers I'd put
three or four more trucks on with you
but they they can't so it is much more
difficult
what yeah what was the question of
Londonderry
thank you
sure
um I I can only say that it's it's um
it's gotten thinner you know where and
uh and part of that is the labor market
or the or the or the inflation or or
things like that so you know we would
hope to typically get five six seven
seven bidders on on projects we consider
it good if we get two or two or three
for the competition we have we have had
a couple of projects that we have not
got any any bids on
um I can't I can't honestly remember
what the Londonderry project was but I
think those are outliers by and large
um typically when we have a situation
like that we'll look at the project and
look at the
uh you know if the work is clear if the
if the schedule is too um too demanding
or get some feedback from the industry
why they didn't bid on it what they saw
in the package in the construction
requirement to make some adjustments and
re-advertise it
so I don't that answers answers your
question
the very few and far between that that
we don't get uh
um interest or that we don't have
bidders on our projects yeah
thank you
um I think you went through this quickly
and I'm not sure if I caught it
correctly or not
um when you're talking about uh you know
we had worked to put money
um for equipment you know for cars to
try to get back on track and how much
you would need and scoping it out are
you there yet are you not there yet uh
where because I think there's been
Improvement but um are you in that cycle
that you want to be in where you can
turn over the cars of fish or plows and
trucks and all in the way that you want
to and get into a sustainable kind of a
cycle
I think we have approached it that had
always been a backlog but again the
recent um the recent budgets and as Dave
pointed out one of the difficulties in
the last year has been while we've had
the resources financially we have not
been able to you know get the the
purchase orders filled because of um you
know delays in the manufacturing side
and things like that
um but I mean the key thing that that
you asked representative Murray was
about sustainability so we have I feel
like we've kind of harped on this at
several budgets the last time because we
did fall so far behind and Dave talked
about the 10 the 10-year life because of
easy math but um you know very simply if
if if we have a fleet that's valued at
around 90 million dollars and it should
be replaced every every 10 years or so
we should be investing about nine
million dollars a year in in that in
that Fleet and in the last few years
through through some capital budget
Appropriations as well as
you know budget Appropriations we have
worked to reduce the the backlog
the sustainability part is the difficult
thing we'll see coming up in this budget
whether whether that those those that
you know nine nine to ten million
dollars a year of sustained investment
to keep on top of that
um will be supported or not
but
go a little bit further with that
um
because it's so hard to get trucks and
construction
um do you have are you going to be
surplusing a lot of money from your
budget this year
of this session of this pass by your
name
uh I don't know we'll have to we'll have
to look at that and and and and see
um ideally I ideally uh and I I'm not
sure if some of those so we have power
we have purchase orders we have money
encumbered it's not spent I believe an
optic in more detail after if we have it
encumbered like that it would stay in
Balance
things like that right
um but with that said we do have a
number of vacancies we have historically
High vacancy rates and in past years we
have had
um higher higher lapses than than we
have um than we have projected so thank
you every time there's a snowstorm since
I've been on this committee I now worry
if the streets are going to get plowed
the highway they will get plowed they'll
definitely get plowed you know but it
may take a little a little longer to to
to you know clean it up but they will
get blocked working hard for you thank
you thank you
thank you Mr chair I just want to follow
up to representative Murray's question
about you know the um
whether you are caught up with a fleet
equipment and whatnot and I heard you
say that you know more funding might be
needed I'm just trying to understand
because the way I look at it if the
department is employing an optimal you
know strategy and handling equipment
that should keep costs to a reasonably
low level now of course if the
department ends up underfunded and has
to step out of that schedule there may
be an initial increase in costs to get
back on the schedule but I would expect
the final outcome to be looking for a
lower overall you know Fleet Maintenance
budget and otherwise am I understanding
this correctly again I'm new here and I
wasn't here the previous year so I'm
liking a lot of context I just want to
make sure I don't misunderstand
something that was said
yes I think you understand it correctly
like I said in in the past years you
know
um you know we have historical data on
on the budgets where we 've been
advocating and saying that we should be
spending about eight or nine million
dollars a year in in Fleet Investments
there are a number of years where we had
budget lines of two or three million
dollars so we we did what we could with
that and the fleet got older and um you
know we had a
um a backlog of of of Maintenance needs
and it becomes a point of diminishing
returns if you're if you're spending a
lot of money to keep
um old outdated equipment running and
and and and and uh and and on the road
um
that that that's why when we do we do
strive for that optimal
um you know getting as much life out of
out of our Fleet and Equipment as as
possible
um but also seeking to replace it when
it becomes
um very outdated or very expensive to
continue to maintain it okay just a
quick follow-up very quick very quick
got it I will wave the follow-up thank
you
okay
sure
but in the verticals construction
industry there's a company called RS
means that publishes construction data
is in the horizontal world you live in
is is there an RS means type company
that gives you here's what it costs to
do this in different parts of the
country yes yeah and there are several
there are several there are several of
those um indices that we follow and
stuff right yeah
right
I will pick it up my myself the last the
last Bureau to touch on
um is a Turnpike Bureau uh turnpike's
comprised of three different segments we
we have
um I-95 from Mass to Maine we have the
Spalding turnpike from Portsmouth to to
Milton and we have the the central
turnpike from Nashua to Concord
um 89 miles long 172 Bridges seven toll
facilities the important thing about our
Turnpike system is it is an Enterprise
fund that means the tolls that we
collect on the turnpike stay on the
turnpike and cannot be used for for
other purposes the other thing is we
have
um needs on the turnpike that include
president preservation and and
maintenance replacement
um and some minor expansion at some
times those tools that we collect today
fund all of those things is people
sometimes think oh the tools were just
supposed to be until we paid for the
transportation the the roadway you know
the tolls continue to operate and
maintain the roadway not just the the
initial construction costs
um so again Turnpike Revenue pays for
operating and maintenance it pays for
our debt service for our bonds that
we've used for construction projects our
renewal and replacement work as well as
our Capital Improvements in fiscal year
22 we had 112 million transactions on
the turnpike system and generated a
revenue of about 123 million dollars
and with that I just um step in here for
one minute because it gets to a question
that representative Murray asked about
about the colors of money and what can
be used on on what so this is the
turnpike system is a very good example
uh as Dave said it's an Enterprise
System uh the toll Revenue can only be
used on on those those those roads so
um sometimes in the budget or the
10-year plan we talk about Turnpike
capital projects when we're talking
about major Bridge projects or or um or
the widening we have completed recently
in Newington and Dover so those are you
know Turnpike funded it doesn't it
doesn't uh we don't use the federal
funds or things like that uh it's just
solely
um
supported by the by the toll Revenue
um David talked a little bit about the
federal funds and the construction
program that's primarily the highway and
bridge program about 220 223 million
dollars a year and again those are those
are funds that that can only be used on
on federal aid eligible highways so in
New Hampshire we have about one-third of
our roadway mileage a lot of the
unnumbered roads a lot of we call them
tier four but they're they're um you
know they're the unnumbered
roads or or the lower uh numbered roads
like like uh like a 110a or something
like that that are not eligible for
federal funds so we have we have you
know we do have in our operating budget
um you know some State funds to support
those but but those are only supported
by those limited State funds so
um and and Andre Andre Brier is here
he's and we introduced you before he's
going to go over some of the Aeronautics
Rail and Transit some of the non-highway
and Bridge things again there are there
are there are silos of of federal
funding that come down specifically for
those uh needs airport money from FAA
can only be used on airports
um Transit money from Federal Transit
Authority Federal Transit Administration
can only be used on Transit so
um I think representative Murray that
that was kind of kind of your question
when we talk about kind of a capital
program or the 10-year plan you know
bottom line has uh some some larger
numbers but but certain funds can only
be used on certain things so
and with that
um I'm Andre go over his
domain
thank you sir and uh I do apologize I
was across the across the street that's
that's why I was a little late I'm Andre
Briere I'm the Deputy Commissioner I've
been in place for about a year and a
half I've spent most of my career in the
federal government I was a U.S Air Force
pilot Transportation official came here
uh after retiring as a U.S Air Force
Colonel so Aeronautics is uh dear to my
heart that's one of the uh items in my
portfolio we have 25 uh open to the
public airports these are small
medium-sized airports for the most part
uh that are really economic gateways to
these communities they're a a key piece
of business infrastructure there's a lot
of companies that won't even open
satellite offices unless they have
access to a corporate jet capable Runway
so these are enablers their search and
rescue platforms their emergency
response
centers and their most importantly for
our diminishing pilot Workforce and the
overall shortage of pilots in our
country that this is this is where the
education starts this is where new
pilots are built and grown so it's it's
in all of our interests to keep them
vibrant and keep them functioning
we have three commercial airports we
know and they largely have uh while we
most of their federal funds do get
passed on through us they have their own
relationships with FAA as well
Manchester Boston in particular uh
Portsmouth and peas and Lebanon
but we are part of What's called the the
uh block grant program so
um 10 states uh to include us uh have
been granted greater authorities to act
in proxy of FAA uh in awarding certain
funds uh to our federal aid eligible
airports we're one of those 10 states
um so we do enjoy greater autonomy that
does mean that that our relationship
with FAA uh is a little bit of a hybrid
one where we act
um on their behalf in certain
circumstances that requires a greater
degree of coordination which in turn
requires a a greater workload from our
DOT employees but we think it's worth it
to our airports
um we collect approximately uh between
four and five hundred thousand dollars
in their uh craft registration fees
every year in addition to the airway
toll of about another two hundred
thousand we use those Monies to fund
operations and also to
um to help with projects at non-federal
Aid eligible airports
um to
repave runways take care of taxiways
things like that and we schedule that uh
on a year by year basis
on the rail side uh we do have about 194
miles of active state-owned track and we
have agreements with six uh rail
operators uh to to operate on those
tracks we have far more inactive tracks
about 333 miles so we try to do uh some
creative things with those to make
maintain them uh and our mandate is to
make sure that they're viable for future
rail if at any point that's desired but
we do things like rail Trails
um the rail bike operators that you see
up in Laconia and also near here in
Concord tourism
uh so we try to maintain those
um the rail trail plan that was just
completed will be uh I think shared more
widely with this committee and others in
the legislature in coming weeks uh for a
for a
a rail trail plan that'll link all of
our rail Trails uh and increase tourism
in the process so that's that's one of
the great things we can do with an
active rail line on the Public Public
Transit side as the commissioner said we
deal with FTA Federal Transit
Administration they're of all the usdot
entities that are probably the easiest
to work with and the most accommodating
and flexible
um and in turn I think we have a very
excellent relationship with our 11 uh
public transit providers here in the
state Coast Concord Coach Bus Express
Etc
we see on the transit side a gradual
return to pre-2020 levels it's a little
spotty there are altered commuting
patterns we see more commuting Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday
less Monday and Friday
this is consistent with patterns that
are really happening throughout the
country where it goes from here who
knows right it's still very much in flux
I've got a I've got a son who entered
the workforce during the pandemic he's
on a hybrid schedule I just told him
don't get used to it oh let's go all
it's gonna take is a recession and
you're gonna be back in the office five
days a week so we'll see we'll see
but we are keeping a close eye on that
and there is a there's a the only thing
I'll mention there is there's a little
bit of a
of dilemma chicken and egg in that if
you do reduce service to acknowledge
current realities then it reduces the
willingness of riders to ride so and
then you get into a doom Loop and so
we're trying to be measured we're trying
not to make drastic decisions right now
until it becomes very clear uh what
these commuting patterns are going to
and just uh before you go on I had
mentioned earlier on a budget slide that
we had a 0.2 percent draw on on the
general fund the general fund really uh
pays for the um Personnel
um in in this in this division uh so
just the dot workers there because the
highway fund is constitutionally
protected to only pay for um
um things related to that to the highway
so
um this division is is a small draw on
the general fund which that's that's
actually an excellent point to make one
additional point the the one item that's
not under Aeronautics is our growing uas
drone capability and and we at dot we
take pictures of things and projects we
don't take pictures of people using our
drones it is much cheaper for us to
operate those uas's than to contract
that work out but as the commissioner
said
we have to you know these are general
fund funded positions
the colors of money come into play here
so if if those uas's are used on Federal
Highway projects how do we how do we
properly build those and fund the
positions that would support those so
this is an ongoing ongoing issue but
we're very excited about our uas
capability and we do we uh just acquired
a drone that can do lidar so you can you
can map ground through trees and it's
fantastic and it really does add value
to our projects
moving on to Administration uh also
under my portfolio at dot we have the
executive office which uh which does
everything that that all agency
Executive offices do
um on the HR side making sure that uh
agency-wide costs are are taken care of
we put a lot of focus on management
strategy on Asset Management that's also
a capability we've grown over several
years under commissioner cass's
leadership we're doing a top to bottom
review making sure we're using our
dollars that are appropriated by this
body in the most efficient way possible
into the into the the greatest effect
and on the finance side uh the colors of
money as the commissioner mentioned are
numerous and very colorful and they
don't mix so our finance office does an
incredible job keeping all that straight
and making sure again that we're using
those in an efficient way we also have a
lot of responsibilities on our project
for federal compliance we have internal
audit as well that makes sure that we're
keeping on the good side of all
appropriate regulations and laws and
under Administration is also policy
formulation and a good amount of
Workforce analytics this is the
discussion that's already happened here
this morning that's talking about
vacancy rates we look at that with a
fine-tooth comb every day
and it's it's unprecedented we have uh
for the most part our Department's
hovering around a quarter of our of our
positions of vacant
um there are some bureaus where that
goes as high as 89 percent there are
some that it's that it's slightly lower
than the average but by and large these
are historic numbers we're seeing just
means everybody is pedaling that much
harder just to try to tread water but
they're doing a great job makes it
incumbent upon us as leadership to make
sure we're as focused as possible during
so last slide that I'll brief uh has to
do with the highway fund that's been
mentioned
so it's a point we always try to make
um and we try not to be patronizing here
but just to make the point that the
highway fund is not DOT and Dot is not
the highway fund they're uh we don't
collect Highway fund revenues that's the
department of safety
um we're also not the only organization
that uses Highway fund Revenue
um
it is a primary source for our operating
budget and you know you're looking at
the split there that you see on the
bottom it's approximately 60 percent of
the highway fund does go to us uh to
fund our activities
um but uh safety uh judicial branch and
Justice also uh get a fair amount of
those monies and a lot of it's passed
through to municipalities
so that roughly covers my portfolio
um Aviation rail Transit Administration
and finance and I'll pause there if
there are any questions on any of those
items
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here and thanks for being Air
Force yeah there you go sir right uh
peace yes what are we doing to uh
maximize that uh asset I mean we've got
11 000 foot Runway which is I mean
that's a valuable asset I've landed
there many times right well welcome yeah
and uh but it doesn't seem like it I I
know the P's base itself is developing
but the the runway that's that's an
awful asset to be just sitting here just
for as little as I couldn't agree more
couldn't agree more and uh in fact last
week we're uh in close coordination uh
with Senator
um Shaheen's office to deal with the
Customs issue that's going on there
right now that gets to your point
exactly we need to make sure that uh our
federal partners are ready to support
the increased traffic flow that we
intend and the PS the peas Development
Authority intends uh to spin up uh and
more fully utilize that asset
um it's a fair amount of consternation
back and forth but with Senator
Shaheen's leadership and her staff I
think we're going to crack it we've got
the right members of my team involved
and I have long history with with
Customs so we're going to make sure that
they accommodate the needs of of
increased traffic flow but it is a
multi-year process agree with you
wholeheartedly that's a big piece of uh
Runway right there that that we need to
utilize more fully you know that can
include things like increased FBO
utilization increased on the private
side certainly the commercial side as
well but we're fully behind those
efforts and uh and in fact I've got a
schedule I'm going to spend a day with
them I believe in two weeks going down
there myself to to talk about future
plans
so with that that covers kind of the
general overview of the department
um the following slide issues and
challenges are some of the things that
we had discussed um
um as part of our budget presentation to
the governor's office and that I
um and we've touched on a lot of these
through through the discussion here
already
um some of those four big bullet points
the inflation we've hit on on that some
of the supply chain issues in terms of
procurement delays particularly with our
equipment Andre had mentioned the
workforce vacancies that uh we had we
are seeing historically High vacancy
rates we have a lot of difficulty
attracting and retaining employees
and especially and Dave had talked about
the hiring of plow operators and hired
trucks and some of the difficulties
there so we don't have real uh answers
other than just highlighting that these
are issues and challenges one of the
aspects of of that
um
uh it also deals with the productivity
so we are
um we are are prioritizing work with
these vacancy rates to make sure that
the light safety make sure the things
that need to get done do get done
um for example
um over this past summer I had mentioned
about the highway striping we try to
stripe every every every road
um once a year if if we can we
historically rely on a lot of temporary
employees we have not been able to hire
those in the past I mean in in this past
year so we are are pulling
um people from the maintenance districts
putting them on the on the striping
trucks to make sure that that work gets
done the consequence of that is there
are fewer people
um in the in the maintenance District
you know doing some of the work that
that they need to in terms of ditching
or replacing pipes or things like that
so some of our work plan productivity
targets um are are are falling off
because of that prioritization of
limited resources similarly this winter
with the snow with a number of the snow
plow operators we had sent out a word
um for people that have CDL licenses
that don't necessarily work in Highway
Maintenance to solicit their
um
uh solicit them to work plowing the
roads this winter and we have about I
think it's about 80 about 80 or so
Volunteers in various parts of the
department that have CDL licenses that
are going to be plowing for us that are
going to be doing winter maintenance
this year because that's our priority
during the winter
that does mean that there's adso people
um that aren't doing their regular job
throughout throughout the winter a
number of those are in are in Bridge
maintenance
um
um they do a lot of work
um you might see some of the bridge
bridge maintenance work alongside of the
road there winter season they put up
enclosures and they and they work on a
number of bridges and stuff but uh again
some of those work work plan targets and
the predict productivity there are going
to be falling off as we prioritize those
resources on what we need to get done so
it is a it is it is a balance uh but uh
you know our fear is that by um
you know prioritizing those critical
areas there are going to be preventative
maintenance work that should be getting
done that that is going to be put off
and could um have
um you know some consequences
ramifications in the future
um but we'll continue to monitor that
and do the best we can
um we had some on on the final page uh
are some longer term challenges that
that we continue to uh
work through
um you know funding
division two Finance I'm sure you're
going to hear this all season long this
there there is that there's never enough
funding to do everything everybody wants
to do
um and particularly on the highway fund
revenues
um you know the highway fund has has
does have some structural deficits it's
been
um balanced by a whole series of of
um one-off
um things every every year to balance it
but it continues to be a structural
balance a structural deficit when you
look at it the the
um the Appropriations the outflows the
expenditures
um exceed annually the the amount of
Revenue come coming in so that is a
again a longer term challenge we also
have a challenge with finding State
funds to match federal federal funds um
we as a state bring very little State
funds
um to our our Highway and bridge program
we are Reliant a hundred percent on the
federal funds for those many other
states have
um more robust state-funded programs to
take care of
both the matching needs for the federal
funds as as well as you know more of the
paving programs and things like that and
I had mentioned about a third of our
highway mileage in New Hampshire is not
eligible for federal funds so that does
continue to be a long-term challenge
those limited State funds for the
non-federal aid eligible highways
yeah thank you I just a very quick
question you were talking about the lack
of matching funds I want to make sure
whether you are talking about the State
losing potential Federal money because
we don't match funds or are you talking
about us our Reliance on federal money
underfunding you know the projects or
both I just again I'm new so
um
well I I I keep phrase the question
basically when you say matching funds
yeah there are scenarios in which we
were supposed to put 10 mil to get five
mil from the feds and we don't put 10
meals so we lose the five mil or you
could say I could also interpret that
statement to be the feds are spending
money on our state but we don't spend an
equivalent fund but that would not lead
to loss of revenues it would just be a
opinion on how much you know we would
need to maintain so I'm just trying to
understand if it's one or both or which
right
um so as far as the the matching of
federal funds we are not in jeopardy of
losing any federal funds for lack of
match there are other states are a state
right next door
um
um Vermont one of their big challenges
uh as I understand it from talking to
our colleagues there
um is uh insufficient State funds to
match the the federal fund so with the
infrastructure Bill and additional
federal funds that are that are coming
um their challenge is going to be
finding State funds to match those
federal dollars
um we have the benefit in New Hampshire
um of of relying on uh um relying on a
uh thing called Turnpike toll credits so
the amount of money that we invest in
our Turnpike system we are able to
um use that as a credit toward matching
the federal funds so currently we have
plenty of uh Turnpike uh investment so
we are not at risk of losing any federal
funds it does mean though that the
federal funds that we do receive don't
go as far as if they had you know
additional safety funds so
just where I was going with my question
thank you
um I travel around my easy pass takes me
all down the coast practically and I go
through all these states and I pay a lot
of money in tolls I go through New
Hampshire I don't pay very much I go to
Massachusetts I go to Maine I go into
New York I really pay a lot of money
um it just it seems like we're and I
love my state and I love the fact that
it doesn't cost a lot to go from one end
to the other but the fact is are we
missing out on something by not raising
um potentially I mean there there is a
New Hampshire has one of the lower lower
toll rates um I just spent the weekend
in in um New York and coming coming
across some of the New York bridges when
they're 15 tolls make our three dollar
total three dollar total at Hampton seem
very uh
um
I know very very uh affordable very a
bargain so but those are public policy
things that that we can that we can talk
about I will say in in past years
through the 10-year plan we've tried to
at least highlight from the capital
program
um you know
what's what what the funding stream on
on the turnpike system what that's doing
to some of those major capital projects
it's extending it's it's extending them
them out
um so those are some of the public
policy choices we'll have to uh debate
and talk about thank you one more just
in terms of the the gas tax
um people using electric cars so I know
there's a lot of legislation coming
toward that but I think these are all
things we've got especially for the work
that you folks are doing I'm really
concerned about where all this money is
going to come from and I know that your
Highway fund has been I I think the last
time didn't we talk about like 40
million dollars that we needed to move
there or do something because it was the
LA at the end of the last session I
think uh the Senate moved 50 50 million
dollars from general fund Surplus into
the highway fund uh ostensibly to look
at um
covering us carrying carrying the
highway fund through this through this
upcoming biennium yeah
thank you yeah you're welcome
do you know what that Gap might be this
year with the highway fund um well I
guess we'll get that one yeah we'll get
that when we have the budget we're all
waiting to see the budget presentation
and things yeah
yeah thank you
um
yeah what was I going to say
the uh it leaded to uh what she was
saying about the 90 to 110 million
dollars in equipment that you have now
in the past I believe we bonded for 20
years a piece of equipment the last 12.
are we looking at in other words for the
people that haven't been on this
committee this is that's an important we
don't want to do that I mean because
after 12 years you don't have the you're
still paying on something you don't even
have correct could you allude to that
so thank you for asking that question
and your various do we did bond for the
equipment the what we did though we made
sure to bond for 10 years and we only
purchased equipment that had a useful
life of 10 years or greater so we could
not use those bonded funds for for our
um automobiles that aren't going to last
10 years but they they were very helpful
for us to catch up on the heavy
equipment that does have a useful life
of 12 or more years
and if I may uh one of the things that
uh you folks do I believe you build your
own trucks and that's that probably
saves money and you in the long run
because you're getting them exactly like
you want and I really appreciate your
what you do on the highways because uh
you know going down that road after it
snowed the night before and they're nice
and clean that's beautiful
so that's all we had we had for
presentation but any further questions
or any other information you'd you would
want for us well selfishly I'm curious
about the
project in Hampton I'm from Hampton okay
and I'm the chairman of the planning
board
and we've got a project hanging out
there to sell sell off the liquor store
stores
property to private Enterprise
to be developed it like Hooksett
where are we in that because that came
before the planning board two years ago
yeah we uh the Department of
Transportation doesn't have any
involvement in that that's all being
worked on by uh um Department of liquor
really yeah yeah we haven't had any
involvement in that
go back and talk about
talk about short uh Workforce vacancies
sure and maybe you could just describe
what you've learned anecdotally from you
know some of your experience in trying
to
fill those vacancies what are you
hearing from applicants in terms of why
um or from you know your experience what
what are some of the causes you believe
of this vacancy rate being so high right
I think the number one the number one
cause has been uh um has been the level
of compensation that the state wage
rates offer we've had particularly in
the operation side uh over the past
several years as cities and towns are
more Nimble or or have more um
flexibility I think
um we've been finding a number of those
Highway Maintenance
positions people are leaving for three
four five dollars more an hour working
in the same town for the municipality
with with I think particularly through
the municipalities they have relatively
similar benefits packages as the as the
uh as the state so I think that has been
the
um that has been the number one
challenge
the overall unemployment rate is is
another thing as well too I mean as we
were talking about it you know
particularly last winter with with our
with our staff you know they they were
seeing the the vacancy right rates climb
and and concerned but at the time you
know every every Dunkin Donuts had had
the hiring and having Limited hours
because they couldn't find
people to work either so I think
um you know the the
compensation rate and and overall
unemployment rate have been the two
biggest factors I'm hopeful I'm
optimistic that um the um
tentative agreement that's been that's
been reached through with the collective
bargaining agreement will will help
mitigate some some of that
certainly we saw uh I I don't know if
you're aware but at the end of at the
end of last summer into into this fall
coming into the winter
um uh through the governor's office and
and um
through the fiscal committee we did get
retention and recruitment bonus
um about five thousand dollars for the
for the winter they get half up front
and half if they stay the whole winter
and when we instituted that
um I I won't say it brought many more
people in but we did we did it did seem
to stem the tide we would
tracking the vacancy rate climbing
climbing and stuff and it did seem to
when when that guy instituted you know
kind of leveled off at that 22 percent
or so is that yeah anything more
yes that you you all the legislature had
passed a law in uh the last
um session to allow Recruitment and
Retention bonuses we targeted that to
our greatest need well we knew you you
all would see on a daily basis towards
uh when a maintenance positions
um and as Bill said that did two things
for us one it flattened the curve so it
stopped
um folks from from leaving didn't bring
a whole lot more but we what we also
used that enhancement for was to invite
people from other state agencies and
from within dot that had CDL licenses to
come in and work with us to do win a
maintenance so we have about a 27
vacancy rate and win a maintenance and
the only reason representative Petrie is
happy with that road condition when he
gets on on the road is because we have
80 internal and 10 folks from other
state agencies helping us to plow snow
this winter now that's getting us by
does that come without issues I had a
phone call this morning and a
conversation about one of those drivers
with less experience on the road so not
a recommended long-term solution but it
certainly got us where we could provide
something that is acceptable to you all
this winter we thank you for for giving
us those tools those are the tools we
need to react more quickly so thank you
all for that support and just adding
what assistant commissioner on to what
he said assistant commissioner rodrigue
we we like I said we track this daily
and you can see the the effect of these
things and that that did really slow the
bleeding we've actually seen a an
improve movement and the actual vacancy
rate when it comes to operations
positions in the last couple weeks
however this is not although we've
addressed operations and we've really
focused on it because that's that's the
business end of dot that's what people
see they see the roads uh especially in
winter in those conditions
this is a top to bottom issue though if
you look at some of our vacancies in our
engineering Workforce they're stunning
worse than than our operations positions
that affects our ability to deliver our
10-year plan long term if we don't have
those that expertise within the
department it not only costs more to
contract that out in some cases that
resource is also tapped because every
state in the country got a whole lot of
iija money that they're trying to spend
and every engineering firm in the
country is going after that work right
so we're in line with a lot of New
England states so it is incumbent upon
us to also go after our engineering
Workforce shortfalls and that's
something that the commissioner has
focused us on as well just just to uh I
don't know if you're aware that the
state purchased a hospital
last year and the way they're Staffing
that hospital is with a contract yeah
not with state employees
uh I mean there are state employees like
six or seven that are quote senior
managers but the whole hospital is a is
a contract Service
relationship so they can pay enough to
have the staff they need right and I'm
I'm only throwing that out there as a
model I'm not saying you can do the same
thing but there may be something there
it's just it's a lot more expensive oh
yeah oh no doubt about it but at least
it gets done yeah and the other thing
that came to mind when you talk about
trucks and independent contractors if
they're paid hourly that's a that's a
very fragile relationship I mean I'm not
going to go out and spend 150 200 000
for a truck in case you're going to call
me
so it seems like there's somewhere down
the road there may be a public private
strategy to help people that want to be
independent contractors funding their
trucks or or somehow helping them be
successful but that'll have to be
Revenue with with a minimum for the
winter I mean
I've been involved in Condos for quite a
while and we don't have contractors by
the storm
our our contractors to do snow removal
get paid whether it snows or not
some years they win some years they lose
but it's a flat rate so I'm just again
keeping everything a variable cost
seems like it's going to be probably
more problematic if our labor situation
gets worse that's all right just
throwing it out that's a good point I
know I know with our with our with our
Hyde plows we do they are guaranteed a
10 hour minimum a week so we do they
they have some Revenue stream that they
can Bank on and and stuff so um
and there are other there are other
models similar to what you said we've
looked uh we've worked closely with
colleagues in at Maine DOT who have um
I don't know if it's called
experimenting but they have gone down
the road of Contracting out uh some some
of their um winter maintenance some of
their maintenance operations and stuff I
think to mixed results is to make three
great uh thank you uh I'm really happy
to see the tolls on the total operators
being taken out of Rochester and Dover
are you playing it and how much money is
that save and are you planning to do
that for Hampton also Beyond you know we
spanned the Hampton uh
tall
oh wow so was that as I go with that
plan to remove them all
uh we don't have a plan at this point to
to move the whole system to all
electronic tolling like Massachusetts
did
um Rochester and Dover as um as a as it
as as those uh barrier toll plazas were
dated and and and needed some sort of
investment you know we looked
um both at Open Road tolling like it
exists in Hampton and
um
um hooks it and all electronic tolling
and and with the state of the uh um the
industry and where it's going the
technology as well as as you mentioned
kind of the cost Savings of of not
having to maintain a full-time
um staff of
um
toll takers
um that that's that's the um that's we
talked with Spalding Turnpike as as
those other plazas uh require some sort
of investment in the future we will have
to see so the next one
um that we have planned for work is uh
is the Bedford toll plaza and right now
in the 10-year plan we are and we have
authority through through some of the
discussions with the legislature for uh
similarly doing all electronic tolling
on on that
um but as far as the other the other
major uh toll plazas nothing in the
plans yet but
um my supposition would be particularly
in Hampton I know
um and and some degrees hooks it those
two lanes of of Open Road tolling are
are getting to be on those Peak weekends
they're getting to be a bottleneck so as
we uh looking down the road at those
toll plazas whether to add a um
another uh another Lane for open road
tolling or whether to remove the plaza
um completely and go all electronic
tolling those are things we'll have to
evaluate and go through the process
follow-up how much money does that save
and uh you know between taking out the
tolls and how how hard is it to collect
uh you know for people that try to run
the tolls and not pay
uh I don't have that information uh on
the tip of my uh things but I can look
into it and get get get some information
to you for that I know we had similar
questions from the executive council at
a recent um
at a at a recent um
contract the design contracts for the
Bedford toll plaza so
um I know we're working on getting
getting that as far as the collection we
do have a um a
a pretty robust back office system
um through through uh
um you know through sending
notifications escalation of that to um
to uh fines and ultimately to putting
putting people in um
uh suspension of um
registration rights in order to get the
um in order to get the payment for those
tools so
we do well we have reciprocal agreements
with at least Maine and Massachusetts to
to the bigger biggest
um
I wanted to
tell for shortage sure conversation uh
just to see what is your feeling about
um our comparison
rates with our New England neighbors are
we I mean I assume the problem is
universal across the United States but
um you know specifically in New England
how do we fare in terms of our neighbors
um I'd I'd have to check I don't have
the numbers of my sense though
anecdotally is that we are behind them I
know um last winter when we were having
similar concerns and debates
um
for whatever reason however they're
structured both Vermont and
Massachusetts were were able to put in
place
um
um pay raising increases for those for
those Staffing
um I I'm not quite sure how they're
collective bargaining or how their um
things are structured but um
um both both Vermont and Massachusetts I
know have had recent pay increases which
put them above and I think Dave you
might know I know um
Maine had done a similar thing I think a
couple of years ago
um
I think they're they're
their enhancement was uh
accomplished very similar to
um how like Health and Human Services
have have done have have addressed the
nursing shortage you know they've gone
to government council with a enhancement
wage targeted specifically for those
workers so so between again anecdotally
um what what I know has transpired at
our three neighboring states I do
believe that we are
um
so I think just a quick follow-up
question to the you know uh occasional
inability to collect dolls and that
suspension of driver's license is a
mechanism to collect that
it's something that you know I always
struggled with as a matter of policy
because it has a lot of negative impacts
would
similar you know result would be
obtained by for example not suspending a
driver's license but tacking on the
unpaid toll fees to say the registration
next year obviously that would work less
for people out of state but I'm just
trying to see if the department would
have any thoughts on what may achieve
the same goals in a less you know
punitive or
harmful manner you know even though that
should be paid I mean I'm not a fan of
anybody who doesn't pay
um I I think by the by the uh I think by
default by the suspension of of of
registration privileges it does get to
that um I don't know if uh there would
be the authority to
tack on those those costs to their to
their registration fee I mean the
registration fees are set in statute and
things statutes would need to be
adjusted I'm just asking in terms of
your thoughts on whether that would be a
you know feasible approach and I know
I'm asking you to speak you know right I
think by default I think by de facto
that's what we that's what we try to get
at
um by the revocation of their um
registration privileges they can't
register the vehicle on until they you
know until they pay those fines so thank
you
the quick question about housing
um work the cost of houses
in the state of New Hampshire it's
extraordinary
um it this has to be impacting your
folks
so that's something that that we really
need to work on
I'm thinking yeah
I couldn't provide you more than
anecdotal data but uh I think both Dave
and I were up in the North Country not
too long ago talking to some of our
Highway maintainers who had to leave
their hometowns because they could no
longer afford to live there
um yeah it's heartbreaking and these are
and it also adds to their days and it
means they're taken on second and third
jobs there was I'll I'll provide you
just a a a small anecdote from from that
same visit from a different person who
is doing a full shift at Amazon
getting off that shift and coming to
plow our roads now is that safe
no
it's not it's what this person has to do
to put food on the table and put a roof
over their head so yeah there's there's
a lot of things that that would benefit
from being addressed in that whole
scenario
thank you um if it were possible I'd be
curious to know what we would need in
order to be competitive with Maine or
Vermont
um I don't know if that's you know a
number that you would have but how much
money would you need in order to pay
comparably with the other states and
this is totally an embarrassing Pre-K
question
um
at what level do you set your hourly
rates as I know we give you a budget but
then there's a big gap between us giving
you this budget money and you deciding
to pay this much money for the snowplow
person
um what flexibility do you have in terms
of how much you're able to pay your
people
um we we have very little flexibility in
how much uh we are so so we are bound by
the state classification system
um we're all fit into that in terms of
that
um there are
there is a um there is an effort
underway through dop to uh revamp the
state classification system and
hopefully in the future
tie it more closely to
um
standardized classes so that we could
more readily compare how State wages
for certain classifications of work
compared natural and compare regionally
or nationally to Department of Labor
Statistics so
well thank you for your attention I know
it's a long couple hours but hopefully
we answered all your questions and uh
we're very thankful for the opportunity
to meet with you so thank you
foreign
okay so one o'clock we'll
we'll published as a one o'clock start
so we'll start at one o'clock
it's a good
well you learned from the meeting huh
they told us
yeah yeah he gets too and actually
probably he gets three because uh okay
no well no
I know but he could have he could yeah
that actual most was for he didn't have
to have two women oh that's only for
public hearings what we're doing all the
ones we get from the uh Commissioners is
is I have a pile and put it in file just
like yesterday we got all that
information if somebody ever wants a oh
geez I misplaced mine or whatever that
goes on how to make a copy and I made
that resume
um
okay and and I talk again about it and I
mean it's a good idea I mean it's you
okay
well good afternoon
um everyone my name is Bob Quinn I'm the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
with me here today is Steve Lavoy the
director of administration
um just to get us started here uh
director Lavoy has put together what I
believe is very comprehensive uh but
narrow and defined scope of what our
agency does our seven divisions and I
will just open with and I think
everybody knows the mission of the
Department of Safety is to continually
enhance the safety security and quality
of life in New Hampshire through
professional collaborative and
Innovative service to all and what
guides our mission is our vision which
is to make New Hampshire the safest
state in the nation with the highest
quality of life for all what I am going
to do is um I am going to turn it over
to director Lavoy he's going to go
through division by division we'll have
a time for questions after each one but
again we want to be um respectful of
your time
great thank you commissioner good
afternoon everybody
um so on page three of the presentation
here we have an overview of the
Department of safety's structure and so
as you can see there are seven divisions
within the department each with a
specific Public Safety Mission and then
the office of the commissioner that
provides leadership and oversight over
those divisions what's important to note
and we'll talk a little bit about this
today is that each of the divisions is
funded very uniquely and there are lots
of different sources of funds that
support Public Safety in the state and
so we'll we'll touch on that a little
bit today but that'll be in more detail
when we get into the budget discussions
actually
so page four we'll start with the office
of the commissioner and the office
provides executive leadership and
direction to all seven divisions of the
Department of Safety
on page five it shows the structure
within the office of the commissioner
you can see the Commissioner's Office
includes the office of Highway Safety uh
the legal unit and the Bureau of
hearings we also have two assistant
Commissioners that assist in ensuring
that we have proper direction and
support as a department as a whole
on page six here are some highlights
from the Commissioner's Office direct
report areas so the office of Highway
Safety develops and implements Statewide
highway safety programs designed to
reduce traffic crashes and with the
resulting deaths injuries and property
damage and they administer the highway
safety Federal grant program and that
funds a lot of additional overtime
patrols for enforcement activities at
the local level
there's a public information officer
which ensures timely consistent
messaging on all Department activities
and then the legal unit provides legal
services to all divisions and programs
within the department
we're talking Council on administrative
rulemaking labor issues civil
liabilities right to no requests and
also ensuring that
um we're following all federal state
laws and regulations
and finally under the office of the
commissioner is the Bureau of hearings
and this unit conducts Administrative
Hearings criminal prosecution and select
circuit courts litigation of hearings
appeals and also oversees the New
Hampshire Motor Vehicle Industry Board
they're conducting hearings in person
and by video
and over the course of a year they
conduct over 14 000 hearings and
on page seven
um
page seven shows the funding for the
office of the commissioner the FY 22
actual FY 23 adjusted authorized budget
and then the agency phase requests for
24 and 25 and so again these are here
really just to give you a framework of
how each one of our divisions is funded
we'll go into more detail once we're
speaking to the governor's budget but
the office of the commissioner has
funded predominantly for operations by
Highway and general funds the federal
funding here represents primarily grants
to locals through the office of Highway
Safety and the homeland security grant
program
there any questions about the office of
the commissioner in the areas there so
far
okay
moving on to the division of
administration
the mission of the division of
administration is to improve Public
Safety by providing the highest quality
Support Services to the Department of
Safety and its divisions in the areas of
Revenue collection expenditure reporting
and management of Human Resources grants
budgets and Assets in the picture here
on slide 8 these are members of our road
toll Bureau at the Sprague terminal over
in Portsmouth on top of one of the large
tanks that stores the fuel product when
page 9 shows our administer our the
structure of the dear division of
administration which is comprised of six
bureaus
um again Financial Human Resources
dealing with inventory Asset Management
Road till Bureau which collects the
state's gas Tax Grants management
responsible for compliance over federal
grants and the facilities management
Bureau which ensures that we fund all of
uh that we properly maintain all of our
facilities
see that you've got 85 classified and
two unclassified
um how is your
um Are You full staffed or are you down
like everybody else or what's your
employment situation yeah so um
our within the division is similar to
the department as a whole our vacancy
rates are right around 16 to 17 percent
um some bureaus are fully staffed some
have one or two vacancies others were
struggling to find individuals to fill
in this division in particular the the
road till Bureau Auditors is a section
that we're struggling to find qualified
candidates most of our other bureaus
were were successful in hiring new
people that's not to say we have seen
hiring pick up over the last I'd say
three or four months
um prior to that it was very very
challenging but we are hiring at a at a
higher rate than we have previously and
we're starting to recover those those
roles just to add to that representative
so weekly Steve's team sends out a
dashboard which shows what are our
vacancies across the seven divisions so
we can really look and see where do we
need to increase our recruiting or and
then we ask the question why why are
these positions harder to filled another
so as to director of The Voice we we are
and I think a few other areas in the
department I mean I know we'll get to
the divisions but under the HR umbrella
um Troopers so Troopers are a concern
um you know right now there are 64
vacancies
um in State Police uh there were 10
hires that just came on board last
Friday and then we have
um well over 57 individuals who have
signed up to take the exam this month
and that number is increasing so again
we're seeing that same Trend in all
areas where there's increased interest
in in applicants that we haven't seen
for some time
uh the other area that's that's
struggling is um again and these are
unique roles
um 911 telecommunicators so 901 call
center operators
um significant vacancies in that area
demanding job important job
um rewarding job but it's it's finding
the individuals who are willing to work
in that in that environment
um and um it's been it's been a
page 10 shows some service highlights
for the division of administration
the financial management and planning
Bureau processes over 74 million dollars
in payment transactions
um 19 000 payment vouchers 3000 P card
transactions 155 governor and executive
Council items totaling over 61.4 million
dollars and 19 fiscal committee items
over the last year totaling 37.9 million
dollars
the facility management Bureau insures
all 35 facilities that operational
facilities for the Department remain up
and running and they also oversee
capital projects related to our
facilities so they coordinate very
closely with Public Works making sure
that our needs as a department are met
while they're ensuring that the the
contractors are
following up on their on their
agreements and producing good quality
product for us
the grants management Bureau ensures
Federal compliance over
228 million dollars in Grants and they
administer directly 4.4 million in
Homeland grants 1.2 million in Granite
shield grants and a million dollars in
body camera grants to local governments
the relative Bureau which collates
collects the state's gas tax collects
181.5 million dollars in revenue for the
highway fund the gas tax is currently
22.2 cents per gallon the bureau also
licenses Distributors Transporters
alternative fuel dealers and
international fuel Tax Administration
licensees
they also license oil discharge and
Pollution Control licensees as well and
that's on behalf of Environmental
Services since there's a lot of overlap
between those customers that's a service
we provide for Environmental Services
there's also the audit function which I
mentioned which we saw the photograph of
some of our staff 108 audits conducted
5.6 million audited and a hundred and
two thousand dollars assessed the
importance of that function is that
we're ensuring and trying to promote
voluntary compliance
um if you're not looking people tend to
take Liberties and so the fact that
we're looking is critical it's not so
much the revenue that we generate
Human Resources management very clear of
course oh yeah
okay
thank you
um I think if I recall correctly in the
last biennium
there was money and I don't know if it
was from us or from federal but to help
local law enforcements with body cameras
can you speak to Halls using the body
cameras now both at your level and also
what you know about it being used at
state and local or local levels
okay yeah so um what what I can say now
representative is that all of the New
Hampshire State Police are up and
running with the body cameras I can
provide a list after of you know which
departments have
um been given Grant dollars and and
again we we still have there's money
available I think we have approximately
600 000 left so
um the grants management team has put it
out to the public but again we can only
make the funds available but if you
would like a list of you know who has
participated in that and I we will
provide that information I think some of
that might have to come from police
standards and training
that's you know I would not spend a lot
of extra time on that that's okay but we
can give you a list of what we've put
out through through our program yeah
just agreeing with a statement I wasn't
trying to thank you
the human resources management Bureau
processes payroll for 1600 over 1600
employees every two weeks and FY 22 we
onboarded 528 employees and so again
we're hiring and we're filling those
vacancies
and then finally the asset and Resource
Management Bureau is responsible for
ensuring that all of our inventory and
equipment is properly tracked and
maintained they operate the automotive
garage and repair almost 1500 repair and
maintenance jobs each year
um 882 000 documents were produced by
our copy center and we also manage the
plate room by delivering 557 000 license
plates and over 1.8 million decals to
the municipal agents at 230 towns that
participate in that program and then
finally there's an active mail room as
well 1.8 million pieces of incoming mail
and 1.3 million pieces of outgoing mail
on page 11 is the funding for the
division of administration
a lot of this the primarily primary
funding sources are Highway and general
funds but the other funding source is
really where
um we we apply our indirect cost uh
recovery for the Department to the
dedicated funds that we support and so
that that's comprised of funding from
the 911 fund watercraft safety cost of
collections criminal records and also
the fire fund and again that's based on
the services we provide for human
resources grants management invoice
processing all of those support
capacities we provide to the divisions
as of the department
any questions related to the division of
administration
okay
moving on to page 12 a Division of Motor
Vehicles their mission is to enhance
Public Safety on the roadways of New
Hampshire by ensuring that drivers
vehicles and service providers are
properly credentialed and by providing
resources for the maintenance of our
the the goal is to achieve safe drivers
safe vehicles and safe roadways
and the picture here is director marasco
with a new individual who just received
her license for the first time and this
is a new social media program that the
director has put into place so when you
get your license you can have your
picture taken in front of the
to the Department of Safety DMV board so
it's really been a nice a nice addition
I just want to say Kudos on your great
electronic system to renew your licenses
I just am so impressed how easy it is to
get in and get it done
um I hope maybe we can share that
conversation
yeah no no thank you and and that's
that's really been a focus for DMV
um it's if you think about it I don't
know that there's any other area of
state government that impacts so many
residents
um and there's a lot of volume that
flows through that operation and the
focus is on customer service you know
how do we get the transaction process
that we need to have processed for the
customer
um technology is one answer and and
limiting the number of people who have
to come in person helps to speed that
process along and so we are always
looking at new opportunities to expand
on that and we'll continue to do so so
I'm glad to hear that it's working out
as a satisfied user I just renewed my
license
uh I got the letter with the code went
in and it was 10 minutes tops yep Kudos
uh so on this page we see the DMV
structure um which is broken into uh
several bureaus Bureau of driver
licensing financial responsibility
operations registrations and title and
anti-theft as well as their
on page 14 some DMV service highlights
the driver Licensing Bureau performed 36
200 over 36 200 skills and road tests
and produced 381 497 driver licenses ID
cards uh generating 15.1 million in
Revenue
the financial responsibility Bureau
ensures timely and accurate processing
of actions impacting driver history
records they process 5.9 million in plea
by mail ticket Revenue and the title in
any theft Pro issued 405 167 motor
vehicle titles generating 9.6 million
dollars in Revenue
the registration Bureau process is over
1.6 million Motor Vehicle registrations
each year generating 89.9 million
dollars in revenue and the operations
Bureau provides customer service and
processes DMV transactions at 14
locations across New Hampshire they
field 412 000 customer calls they also
are processing on the back end those
online transactions that require some
additional action by those folks
on page 15 we show up yeah
thank you what there was talk before
that some of the DMV locations had to
close because they weren't being used
can you speak to where you are on the
DMV locations or am I misremembering or
every every DMV location is open yep
the DMV is funded by Costa collections
um and so you can see that that's the
vast majority of their funding there's
some other funds in there those are some
dedicated funds the plate fund
motorcycle rider training and then
driver education as well but that's
small dollars it's really you know 30
million dollars in approximately 30
million dollars in Costa collections on
page
16 we have an excerpt from
the State Constitution and rsa99
defining what Costa collections are
essentially it's it's the cost of
collecting the highway fund revenues
before those revenues hit the highway
fund so the DMV is authorized to recover
their operating costs whatever's left
from those collections that we just
spoke about is transferred into the
highway fund but the statute and the
article the Constitution are there just
for for your awareness the other area
that's funded in this is the road toll
Bureau which I mentioned before the
state's gas tax so they're funded with
cost of Collections and then a small
portion of the commissioner's office and
the division of administration because
of the allocation of those internal and
direct costs
you spoke thank you Mr chair you spoke
earlier about
um the need for technological
advancements to shorten the customer
um interaction time with the DMV and um
I just wanted to ask I know other states
have an um invested in
remote kiosk machines for various DMV
low
um
like low Personnel needed transactions
such as renewing driver's license is
that something that's kind of on your
radar and you know is that investment
just too far out in the future for New
Hampshire or is that something you're
kind of kicking around so so
um we have separate from this
presentation there's several ongoing
projects that have been funding at the
DMV
um that it that hit the DMV they're very
large projects that need a concept
document and a team to once we get the
fund and get it you know to to
completion
um Mo the ones that that I can think of
right now a tail or two
um the IRP program you know commercial
registrations getting that all online so
that you know the they can get their
plates and get their updates one of them
also touches the plate room so as you
see the amount of plates that get
requested from the locals and then it's
direct to The Voice team that's got to
do that so he's looking at automating
that I know that director marasco is
looking at right now what by Statute has
to be done in person there are several
transactions that have to to meet Amber
standards and real ID but any areas
where we can we are looking at that so
to the kiosks and I can't speak specific
to that but um and and I think to your
point that might work in some of the
DMVs but they look at metrics like how
many customers come in what are the wait
times so they they track that every day
what's going on in Milford what's going
on in Concord what's going on in Epping
we have a few that are part-time
Haverhill North Haverhill and Colebrook
so but but I'll follow up on the kiosks
and and it offered to you that um
the more transactions that can be
performed online regardless of if a
kiosk or on your home computer the
better
oftentimes if the customer is coming in
they're expecting personal interaction
and then if we steer them towards a
kiosk or a computer we're somewhat
defeating that expectation
um but um to your point there's a time
and place for all these things and I
think that the DMV is doing a good job
of considering all the options and
um
being strategic about where we invest
our funds to have the the biggest impact
where the DMV touches the most
I would say constituents of each of
yours I think it's important to know too
they're looking at all these phone calls
and trying to determine how do we how do
we educate what we want to make sure is
that the customer understands what's
needed so we don't want anybody to come
to the DMV if they don't have the right
paperwork no matter what transaction
it's for so that's why we have those
greeters and we want to do it online
when we start getting a lot of calls
like say for example in title we look
and say why what is what has got to be
cleared up so we've really I will say
like the title backlog I'll speak to
that specifically we were we were
approaching 40 000 in a queue and it's
gone down as low as 5800 I think this
morning so they're really looking at the
process and and again it comes down to
making it simple what are we doing
online what can we do but just just
educating but I know that we've really
focused a lot on on the commercial side
because
um you know these these companies are
paying a lot of money for these vehicles
and they want to get them at expected
and registered and on the road as quick
okay moving on page 17 the division of
State Police is dedicated to providing
the highest degree of law enforcement
Services throughout the state of New
Hampshire while maintaining the
traditions of fairness professionalism
and integrity
this is our largest division and you can
see on page 18 from the organizational
structure they cover a lot of ground
we've got the operations Bureau which
are your traditional troop stations
splitting the state up geographically
there's special services that fall under
there the state police the state office
complex police force Marine Patrol
G which is uh enforcing commercial Motor
Vehicle Laws across the state so they
have a Statewide Mission as opposed to
just within their troop station
and then on the right side of the
organization there's the investigative
in criminal justice information section
Investigative Services include the major
crime unit narcotics investigations unit
special investigations unit terrorism
intelligence unit and then the Justice
information Bureau this is dealing with
criminal records sex offender registry
permits and Licensing and also the J-1
system which connects the criminal
justice system throughout the state so
that information is passing between the
courts and law enforcement and DMV and
and also Corrections electronically
instead of pushing paper whenever
there's a criminal justice action that's
taken
[Laughter]
that's okay commissioner Quinn is me
covered there can you speak a little bit
to the mobile enforcement team because
there's been the lawsuit there have been
some questions around the mobile
enforcement team so if you can if I
don't know if you're going to do it here
or doing it later but an update on the
Emmy
shorts uh specifically what would you
like represent what would help you can
you speak to the there's a current
lawsuit right now
um with regards to profiling can you
speak to is it possible to speak to that
well yeah well I can't speak to the to
the specific cases but what I can say is
what you know what's the mission of the
mobile enforcement team you know the
mobile enforcement team as as as each of
you know we are really seeing an uptick
in um in deaths from overdoses uh it's
it's no secret that fentanyl is brought
into the state you know their mission is
to hopefully interdict intercepts stop
those drugs before they get into the
communities and kill people however they
have to continuously be trained and
understand state law federal law the
Constitution our policy to make sure
what they do adheres to that
um you know in any of these uh cases no
matter what type of criminal case it is
whether it's a uh a traffic case a DWI a
homicide are a mobile enforcement case
if evidence is suppressed you know it's
always important to look back and see
what could be done differently but the
mobile enforcement team does does have a
mission uh in in our Public Safety
um requirements
um and uh but we will continually I know
that the colonel
pays very close attention to this and we
continually will will look at whatever
oversights needed there and to continue
to learn and work with our our
prosecutors in these cases yeah it was a
great ride-along to do with the Met to
go right along with them was really
um very educational very interesting
will they also pick up on human
trafficking
they can all Troopers can we have one
trooper I mean I think what's important
to understand for everybody every
Trooper has the authority to conduct a
stop and do it do a search so we want
all of our Troopers every Troopa has to
understand and they do the colonel does
a very good job with that our policies
but but the laws change case Law changes
but understanding you know when you
might have exceeded the scope of the
stop or so I guess all Troopers have to
be trained to a certain standard they
are
case you know evidence will be
suppressed it happens and there's a
difference I think between doing
something that's you know outside of the
law and doing something that is
suppressed so
so that's so so the mobile enforcement
team is working and they fall under the
oversight of the kernel the New
just my question is um again it's the um
hiring issue
um you've got 578 how many actual do you
have
so there's of the 578 that's the total
Bureau so that includes civilian rules
too so there's 360 Trooper positions
um that are that are authorized and
funded so I and my question is really
how many people are you down in that so
we're down 64 Troopers okay yeah and
what about in the labs and all the other
areas that you've got
um
last time yeah then we don't have as
many vacancies in in the other areas
um those have been recovering like most
of our other sections in the department
um the Troopers have been a a
more challenging recovery because we can
only hire new individuals at a certain
time during the year they have to go to
the academy
um all the other positions vacancies we
thank you Mr chair just a quick
follow-up in regards to the you know
shortage of Troopers
um I'm you know new on the committee so
I I just wanted to understand how is
this evolving from previous years what's
the trend and what is that you could you
know do or what support would you need
to help you know improve that situation
because obviously being down 20 of your
staff is a significant burden
yeah I think I think a lot has already
been done and um there's some more
things that are that are in the works
and they're all starting to have the
desired impact so
um
foreign
we lost a lot of individuals during the
pandemic people retired early people
made life choices not just in State
Police but across the board and so we're
still digging out from that
um there there is a retention
um and recruitment bonus that was
approved by the legislature by the
council that has been helping to bridge
the gap between the cost or not the cost
but the pay that locals are offering
it's really it comes down to to pay in
many cases when an individual if they're
choosing to enter the law enforcement
they could make more money at a local
level than they can at State Police
today today
um you know there's obviously there's
ongoing negotiations with the Union
we're assuming there will be some sort
of an increase that comes from that you
put all those pieces together and it's
more attractive to to join State Police
in your law enforcement career and to
stay with State Police if you're already
a member and so by by dealing with both
retention and Recruitment and and
addressing one-time pay but then also
long time pay I think that's that's
helping the situation
so just as a very quick follow-up I'm
from Windham and uh you know you think
locals are poaching you we cannot hire
police officers either and we've been
trying really really hard so the the
shortage seems to be systemic and it may
affect the state a bit more because of
the factories you were describing but
it's not like we have uh the number of
officers we'd like to have so it's it's
tough overall thank you you know and I
think what's important is
um you know money is important but I
know that the the colonel and his team
do a very very good job no matter what
the trends are what the year is to make
sure that people that do come through
our process understand what they're
signing up for understand the
opportunities but also understand the
requirements and the oversight and we
get people that are going to want to
stay and we can retain them for a career
and quite honestly some people might
like to go to a a local department or a
smaller department or a large Department
some folks might like to do you know
work in the highway or work it up so I
think no matter what's changed we have
to stay focused and and and stay the
course on our testing and our standards
thank you Mr chair
I live in Manchester
um we have a horrible
unhow situation Complicated by the drug
situation are your Troopers seeing the
same kind of scenarios in other parts of
the state and they and how are they
dealing with all this
I'll take that well first I'll say the
the colonel colonel noise has a
tremendous relationship with Chief
alderberg in Manchester if they need our
help we give it if we need their help we
give it if we don't we continue to you
know do our jobs you know there are I
what we do is I would I would encourage
everyone here to look at the um the drug
monitoring initiative that's posted
publicly that the um New Hampshire
information and Analysis center pushes
out because of what it shows you it
shows you what is happening you know in
in your towns your your counties but yes
we're seeing it we're focusing on you
know where where are folks dying and why
but um I don't think there's any area of
this state that hasn't been touched by
the Fentanyl and what we've been dealing
with recently is not only uh if you go
back a snapshot snapshot of the lab 2010
we were dealing with prescription drugs
unregulated prescription drug abuse 2012
and I'm just going by my memory so don't
hold me 2012 we started seeing an uptick
in heroin the oxycontinent to heroin
then as we address that we and at one
point we had two fentanyl items in the
lab one was a lollipup and one was a
patch diverted from you know from a
medical uh issue and then the fentanyl
hit and that's when we dealt with
fentanyl and carfentanyl and now we're
dealing if you you've read
um with xylazine which is being added to
the fentanally cut so the xylazine can
have an adverse effect on the Narcan
naloxone so so we I think our folks at
the Intelligence and Analysis Center are
looking Statewide I think local law
enforcements to investigate EMS they're
trying their best to deal with it but a
lot of this is you know it's enforcement
but it's public health too messaging and
awareness but but we're seeing it and I
think quite honestly we're just doing
the best we can with it
on page 19 we've got a listing of
service highlights for state police
the operations Bureau which provides law
enforcement Services across seven troops
and through Marine Patrol stops 74 671
motor vehicles and arrested 753 impaired
drivers and conducted a hundred and six
thousand four hundred forty six
commercial vehicle inspections and
weight checks last year
the special services section also falls
in this area and these are highly
trained individuals and special
activities including Aviation canine
Collision analysis and reconstruction
also known as the car unit the drug
recognition experts explosive Ordnance
disposal and special events Response
Team activities
the Justice information Bureau provides
criminal justice information services
including criminal records permits and
Licensing the sex offender registry and
maintenance of the J-1 Network
and then the Investigative Services
Bureau which includes the major crime
unit narcotics investigation unit and
special investigations unit as well as
the Cold Case unit conducted 6299
criminal investigations
forensic lab under State Police is the
Sole Provider of lab services in New
Hampshire they receive evidence from all
the locals Town police departments
County Sheriffs as well as State Police
fire departments and also federal law
enforcement occasionally will utilize
our services and those include Firearms
tool marks latent fingerprint
Impressions DNA analysis ignitable
liquids detection Controlled Substances
blood alcohol testing and urine and
page 20 shows the state police funding
mix
um
several funding sources the primary
sources being Highway funds General
funds and then a small portion of
Turnpike as well and that's funding the
primary State Police Highway enforcement
activities there's also some federal
funding and some other funding in this
area the majority of that is related to
funds for Marine Patrol which are funded
by boat registration revenues that are
any questions on State Police I I just
have a question about recurring graphs
every graph that we've seen so far 22 to
2022 actual
is increased by about 20 percent
to authorize is that because of
vacancies it is okay yes yeah the vast
majority of that is because of vacancies
a smaller portion is due to
um challenges in receiving equipment
that we needed to purchase because of
supply chain shortages but the vast
foreign
moves on to the division of Homeland
Security and Emergency Management whose
mission is to partner with every
Community to prevent mitigate prepare
for respond to and recover from all
hazards that impact New Hampshire
on the photo that's here is the
Emergency Operations Center within the
ipoc
the division is organized in several
bureaus business and finance mitigation
recovery training exercise and
development community services and then
also radiological preparedness we have
42 full-time classified positions
there's also several part-time I'm sorry
full-time temporary positions that are
Grant funded which have been accepted
through the fiscal committee over the
last year to help process disaster
funding which we've experienced
significant number of disasters and need
the resources in order to distribute
page 23 are some service highlights for
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management
as we mentioned the business and finance
Bureau is responsible for budgeting
purchasing and financial reporting and
they also administer the Emergency
Management performance grant program
which provides federal funds to maintain
an all hazards Emergency Management
um thank you
when um less Freddy um
Homeland Security came there was a FEMA
request
um and in it everything was in a
negative because that's how I guess it
has to be shown that we have to pay up
front now what money does the State of
New Hampshire use to pay up front so we
can get reimbursed by FEMA how do we do
that
maybe I'm not being clear so um the
question is how do we how do we make the
appropriation how do we make how do we
spend before the funds come in exactly
so that item
um
a portion of that item addresses that
issue
um we're able to we come to the fiscal
committee
um and to the council outside of the
budget process and request appropriation
spending Authority that spending
Authority is theoretically funded by
the state treasury so like a loan as a
loan right and then those funds we would
draw federal funds down for those
expenses once they've been made and once
we've submitted through the proper
paperwork thank you
um
uh the community services section
provides Technical and organizational
assistance to 234 local communities and
state agencies including assistance in
developing local emergency operation
plans
and the radiological preparedness
section provides assistance to the
communities and state agencies with
planning training and exercises
associated with responding to
radiological events at Seabrook station
and finally within that section is the
radiological instrumentation maintenance
and calibration unit which calibrates
and repairs screening equipment for used
by the 17 emergency planning zone
communities in and around the Seabrook
station
lastly Homeland Security provides
Regional all Hazard approach to training
exercise and development utilizing Grant
and non-grant funded exercises and
training opportunities for local
partners and stakeholders really their
mission is coordinating emergency
preparedness and response across the
state because we're a small state and
when something happens we need to work
with our partners at the local County
and state levels in order to respond
appropriately
hscm's funding on page 24 is is broken
down they're primarily funded with
federal funds through the grant programs
specifically empg
the increase in federal funds that
you're seeing over time here really has
to do with the disaster grants that we
just spoke about those outflows are
expected to continue into the next
biennium as those reimbursements get
processed and then there's some other
funding which is predominantly Seabrook
assessment funds and then also some
internal grants that we hsem receives
from a highway safety and Homeland
Security through the commissioner's
office
any questions on hsem just a very quick
question thank you Mr chair I'm looking
at the you know budgeted numbers and
your budget your budget increased by
about 10 percent or so on the federal
funding between 22 and 24 and that's
actual versus budgeted so you know the
increase could be different
is that part of those you know grants
and numbers that you are talking about
is it something that the state may have
to pick up if the federal funding dries
out or is it just an inflow of federal
funds that need to be expanded and then
it will return to the Baseline
it is um it's Federal funding uh
predominantly disaster funding no
liability to the state it's really a
pass-through of federal funds through us
to the locals so it's a temporary thing
and at some point it will slow down when
the federal
yeah correct um I mean the one thing
the one thing I'd caution is we're
10 years ago we didn't budget for
disasters at all so we would only come
forward to the fiscal committee when one
occurred we now have uh seven open
disasters it might be eight seven
um and so we're now taking the approach
of we're estimating and budgeting the
disaster funding so that we can keep the
those funds flowing through the system
without having to come to fiscal after
the fact if a new disaster occurs we'll
still need to come to fiscal because
this estimate didn't contemplate that
so I would expect these numbers to
potentially decline over time
but the big increase is is predominantly
because of the coveted disaster it is
eight he was right I'm wrong
see it is eight yeah thank you sir
all right page 25 the division of
emergency services and Communications
their mission is to locate communicate
and connect people in an emergency with
the help that they need and the photo
structure within the division there's a
bureau of communications and
interoperability
the Bureau of Technology Services which
maintains the systems themselves Bureau
of operations which runs the psap
and the bureau of administration which
handles procurement contracts audit
functions HR functions
page 27 shows some service highlights
for the division
the bureau operates two geo-redundant
911 Public Safety answering points we
call those peace apps those are the call
centers in Concord and ones in Laconia
they provide 24 7 coverage and they're
both operational at the same time so if
one goes down the other one is already
taking calls it's not a warm site it's
they're they're hot sites
last year they answered 400 and 181 000
calls and maintained a 51.64 second
transfer time for emergency medical
dispatch calls
um so they're they're transferring that
call to the local area
um in under a minute based on what
they're hearing
99.56 percent of calls are answered in
less than 15 seconds and 99.75 percent
of calls are answered in less than 20
seconds
we've achieved a 99 quality assurance
rate when reviewed when reviewing
5745 emergency medical dispatch reviews
and
4535 Police and Fire reviews
the Bureau of communications and
interoperability is responsible for
overseeing the development of
interoperability radio communications
and training for First Responders and
they coordinate the federal state and
local communication needs with it within
New Hampshire
radio communications those individuals
engineer install and maintain the New
Hampshire state police radio system and
then the Statewide microwave back hall
and all the support facilities
associated with those including
generators at tower sites
they currently support 39 microwave
links and 29 transmit receive sites
and finally the Bureau of Technology
Services maintains the 911 system itself
to ensure there's an interrupted call
answering and transfer services and then
they also maintain the databases that
support the telecommunicators so they
can direct the calls and direct the
services where needed that's the gis
system the geographic information system
and the automatic location information
or the Ali databases currently at our
mapping database holds 708 312
addressable points across the state so
it's really it's important the more
points you have the more accurate you
oh thank you Mr chairman
um
dead spots you're good how's your
coverage I mean uh we I know what the
county we have uh matter of fact we're
updating our system of Stratford County
to uh you know prevent dead spots and
obviously we have some very
remote locations in New Hampshire
especially up in the North Country
yeah
all right I'll you can back clean up
I'll take that so we have um we have a
position to switch Statewide
interoperability coordinator John
Stevens who works over there side by
side with Mark Doyle who's in charge of
uh of desc 9-1-1 so they've got they
work with the network engineers and
we're looking right now they're looking
at an upgrade I believe it's in The
Troop C area Sullivan County they're
also looking at troop F we've been
focusing now on the border you know
looking for where are the gaps but they
are continuously doing that with on our
state system the two systems that we
have
um so I think the key to your point is
understanding the difference in systems
you know we've got our Statewide system
we've got b top which you know rides
rides around that so you know behind
that
but we we are continuously looking at
the dead spots and trying to come up
with solutions for you know for that but
I can tell you the team that we've hired
in the last several years are really
good we've got some great radio
technicians and if there is a spot that
they identified not only you know in the
mobile but the Portables they're looking
for Solutions
um but you know a lot of it is uh maybe
the solutions there they it could be a
training issue but we provide a lot of
dollars to support through through the
Homeland grants interoperability but the
gaps still exist I can't speak to the
Stratford County one I'm sure but you
know the team meets together in the seek
the Statewide you know team that looks
at it so I think I think that the gaps
are shrinking again there are some you
know areas where they need a power
source you know it isn't just an antenna
but it's so so I think we're I think
we're going in the right direction
though
if I may uh I worked in that with State
Police and local Stratford County okay
in 1969 so and it's it was good then I
mean it you know because you a lot of
times you worked as a single officer at
night and that's all you had
yeah I was curious about that too and
also as a follow-up because phones are
getting better and you're getting fewer
dead spots um you're getting more calls
from hikers basically or campers
um have you seen an uptick in that
because of an increase in coverage and
um who do they Loop in for the search
and rescue for people who are in the
woods and using 9-1-1 as a way to get
help yeah that's a good that's good we
we were just talking about that so so
there's an immediate response if it's
like a life safety so we dispatch now we
have a tremendous partnership with fish
and games so we help them with the
dispatch so if it's a dispatch calls for
service would go through dispatch if
it's a life safety 9-1-1 you know they
would notify that local area and then
they follow up with a call to fish and
game who handles the rescue so they want
to make sure they get immediate response
to to that whatever the the emergency is
and then they'll call Fish and Game
but but back to your the metrics so I
can't speak as you look at the 911 calls
those continually are increasing so
you'd have to ask fish and game on how
many calls they've been getting for
page 28 shows the funding for the
division of emergency services and
Communications
they're funded predominantly by the 911
fund that's based on a 75 cents per line
surcharge for all telephone lines it's
wired Wireless Vape lines and there's
also a 75 cent surcharge on prepaid
cellular cards as well
and so that at this point that fund is
um been healthy and able to support the
operations including adjustments and
page 29 is the division of fire
standards and Emergency Medical Services
they're committed to training educating
and certifying
emergency and Community responders to
protect the citizens and visitors of New
Hampshire and a photo there some
firefighters and an active training
scenario
page 30 shows their structure broken
into the Bureau of firefighter training
the Bureau of Emergency Medical Services
the Bureau of certification and support
and then the administrative support
function
this bureau there's 40 classified
full-time employees for the majority of
the activity is going to be with
part-time instructors and so we hire
subject matter experts people with
experience for the certain courses that
are being held and that's on a part-time
basis and so when we get to the budget
section you'll see they have a
significant part-time part-time budget
the service highlights for the division
on page 31 the Bureau of firefighter
training they provide all firefighter
hazardous material driver operator
airport rescue firefighter and Technical
Rescue Training and testing across 26
curriculums
they oversee two fire training campuses
one in Concord one in Bethlehem
training props Vehicles apparatus and
Equipment all necessary to conduct the
trainings
last year they enrolled 20 140 students
issued 1 280 certifications and taught
897 courses across the state
curriculum Administration is responsible
for planning developing and implementing
all curriculums including incorporating
just a quick question about electric
vehicles how are people being trained to
deal with them because my understanding
is that they require different treatment
than firefighters usually use for them
yes so so I know that they um
they have uh
one gentleman one investigator from the
Fire Marshal's Office who has gone out
and he has conducted some trainings he's
also met with industry I know he
presented a training to the New
Hampshire auto dealers so we have uh one
member of the Fire Marshal's Office who
understands how to addressify how to
deal with it you know how hot it burns
you know why this won't work that how to
stay away from it so we do have a
subject matter expert who if you know
anyone who needs training let us know we
can we can
that's not me but we do have somebody at
um in addition to firefighter training
uh this division is also responsible for
oversight of EMS activities in the state
and so the Bureau of Emergency Medical
Services manages and regulates EMS
education practical testing and then
provides clinical oversight and protocol
development so they're not actually
doing the training in this case but
overseeing the trainers and the programs
themselves the curriculum
they license sub 5 375 EMS providers and
472 ambulances also responsible for data
management collection and Analysis
including management of the Statewide
trauma system
in the Bureau of certification and
support provides instructor Fire officer
fire investigator and some command
system certifications and other National
Fire Academy training programs
they develop online educational content
for all division programming and manage
course registrations and Billings
including certificate production as well
as oversee the reception staff
just just add to representative Heath
real quick what I'll let you know is uh
the team like the director of the fire
academy the fire marshal Mark Doyle from
9-1-1 and Rob Buxton from Homeland
Security we have gone out and done
Outreach meetings by region with the
fire service call full so we've been to
monagnarok we've been to the North
Country we were just at
um where were we the other night we're
in Lebanon so we're going out and we're
bringing in 15 20 full call part-time
here's what we deliver at the state
level are you missing anything so we've
really done a lot of community outreach
been there you know a couple hours long
but we learn a lot but these directors
have been really engaged to say what
what services are we not delivering or
what need to be online are the times
working are they not and what we find
when we go out there's a lot of
volunteer and call that quite frankly
h32 shows the funding for fire standards
and training and Emergency Medical
Services they're predominantly funded by
the fire fund the fire fund is supported
by fees collected through the sale of
Motor Vehicle driving history records
per predominantly to insurance companies
but to others for authorized use and so
those fees support the fire the go into
the fire fund and support this Division
and also the division of fire safety
which is the next division that we'll
talk about
the other funding section are instructor
fees that are paid for paid directly for
course participation that's where
there's a subsidy that supports the
locals locals are paying 135 dollars for
each firefighter one course and 150 for
each firefighter 2 course which is a
significantly reduced rate if you're not
unaffiliated Department you're paying
four thousand dollars for firefighter
one and 2190 for firefighter 2. so
that's really a critical part of of
um the support that the division
any questions on fire standards and
training
what uh
does this uh do they have to be
certified a certain way uh and
how often
so to be a full-time firefighter in New
Hampshire you need to have passed
firefighter one
um and firefighter two just firefighter
just firefighter one and that allows you
to be a full-time uh firefighter the
part-time
firefighter positions don't require any
certification it's encouraged but it's
not a requirement at that level and
that's why we want to encourage and
support because if the trainings matter
what we don't want is someone to just
sign up so we have to do everything we
can to get the training to those and a
lot of those are volunteers so they have
yeah first of all that's a really good
field trip is to go to the fire that was
a great field trip and I wanted to
follow up about the volunteers how many
communities still really rely on only
volunteer firefighters I mean Newcastle
has only fairly recently hired I think
we have two now I can get you that
number but I'm reminded every time I go
up north it's the majority you'd be
surprised so you know when you look in
you know when you look at Portsmouth you
know the services can be delivered in
Portsmouth and then you go to Lebanon
but then next to Lebanon is the Piermont
or the line Chief and you look at
Hanover I mean it's different and but
they're all good people they just need a
different type of support and um
right uh thank you uh
uh High School
a lot of high school kids want to get
involved in firefighting as a even even
as a volunteer status uh do you interact
with the high schools you know certified
I know I know I think Dover has a
program through their CTE and and this
would be valuable even if we continued
on to a community college system so I
will tell you this based on director
cutting Justin cutting who started his
career in Enfield
went to Hampton finished a full-time
career in a large department and now
he's the director of the fire academy he
worked with Senate Apprentice in a team
to have a retreat Recruitment and
Retention committee there was 12 or so
that came in multi-disciplinary all
walks of life what can we do to enhance
not only recruiting retaining in an
increasing diversity in the fire service
so they looked at it they came out with
a a recommendation but what Justin did
director cutting he secured funding to
have a full-time Recruitment and
Retention specialist that works in there
that's studying this and dealing with
all the communities and engaging them to
help support So to to how do we you know
how do we meet the needs of this city as
opposed to this town so we have a
full-time woman who's working at the
fire academy focused on Statewide
recruitment
so thank you Mr chair just a quick
follow-up question right
what are the qualifications one needs to
you know how does one enter the
firefighter You Know Field assuming they
are looking at a full-time position I'm
from Windham obviously you know we don't
really have uh you know volunteer
firefighters so what are you know how do
you go about after graduating high
school to pursue a career in that field
because I'm pretty sure some of our kids
may be interested but I was never able
to you know figure out exactly what the
right path is sure well it differs but I
think they you know first though they
have to pass a test there's a national
test it has to be you know and that's
done at the at the fire academy and then
they have to
um they have to take the course the the
fire course some departments require you
to be maybe an EMT some require you to
be uh an advanced EMT or a paramedic so
everything's different but I guess the
point is that what we're trying to do is
where it is different and you in some
folks and even director cuttings looking
at Bridge programs how do you get from
paramedic to being a nurse you know it's
easy to go to go from the medical side
to the uh to the emergency management
but it's not as easy to to matriculate
from from our side to this so when I
tell you I don't have all the answers
but they they are focused on this they
are laser focused and they hired
somebody to to look at that so thank you
so I would encourage anybody that wants
to do it we you know we have someone
thank you we have
we had pushback when we're transitioning
from a volunteer to paid staff for the
fire department is that typical do you
see that in other places
we wanted to keep the volunteers it was
unbelievable I I you know what that has
come up at our meetings and I know that
some Chiefs and I believe it's when I
went to the Monadnock region said you
know we I manage that I have full-time I
have call I have this so so these and
again I was never uh I didn't come from
the fire service but I think in some
areas they have to you work with
whatever you whatever you can you know
one thing I I will share is that I was I
was really surprised to see how many
volunteers there were you know and I met
one gentleman who had been doing it for
50 years so there's a lot of there's a
lot of call and volunteer departments
all right page 33 uh is the division of
fire safety whose mission is saving
lives and property through education
engineering and enforcement and this
Photograph here is actually a trailer
that the division operates that shows
the impacts of a room with a sprinkler
and without a sprinkler and so behind
you can see that's the without a
page 34 shows the structure there's a
Bureau of Investigations Bureau of
Outreach and education and a bureau of
building safety and construction and
there's also the administrative support
section
and on page 35 the highlights for Fire
Safety Division the Bureau of
Investigations is responsible for
investigating all fire carbon monoxide
and building collapse deaths they assist
local state and federal agencies as
subject matter experts
they operate the ignitable liquid
detection canine program in the state in
an FY 22 conducted 100 investigations 22
Death investigations nine fire deaths
six coat deaths 29 canine calls and 31
criminal cases with six arrests
the Bureau of Outreach and education
provides life and safety education to
reduce deaths injuries and property loss
last year they delivered 38 educational
classes participated in 44 Outreach
events and conducted 41 K-9 demos
the Bureau of building safety and
construction administers the state
building permit system they conduct
routine Fire and Life safety inspections
of state-owned properties and they also
assist local Fire and Building officials
when asked
last year they completed 1 352
inspections and 1 614 technical consults
they also conduct 1 360 Tramway and
amusement ride inspections over the
course of the year
and they also administer the modular
building and Firework safety programs
the Bureau of planning and support
services conducts Community risk
reduction programs training and Outreach
to local and state Partners emergency
incident data reporting and Analysis
they administer the fire safe cigarette
program and they also coordinate
hazardous material technical assistance
page 36 shows funding for the division
of fire safety just like fire standards
and training they're funded
predominantly with fire funds and a
small portion of General funds for the
modular building program
um the the I'll take a moment to stop
here and just talk briefly about the
fire fund
um for those of you who are returning
members you know that the fire fund has
been we've had some challenges with
funding the fire fund over the past
several years
um as we expected uh the end of FY 23
we're projecting the fire fund
um fund balance to be close to zero
um essentially essentially zero and so
in order to fund the division of fire
safety and the division of fire
standards and training using fire fund
revenues we will need to increase the
fees associated with the data
um that that's currently being utilized
and so we have a request to do so
through our agency phase and we'll have
more discussions about that when the
foreign
legislation on it or
is it okay so this would be through um
the fee structure for these are it's
it's a combination of some um some are
in statute summer administrative rule
um summer
um the commissioner has the authority to
make those adjustments and so as part of
the budget process we would be
discussing some adjustments through
house bill 2.
yeah if if there's not a bill over in
ways and means and we'd have to do it in
hp2 but we'd also coordinate with ways
um so in summary
um we've got seven divisions in team
safety
um our full-time positions and our part
times are all dedicated to Public Safety
um
Public Safety truly is customer service
all of these divisions as you've seen
are delivering Public Safety Services to
the customer that's the residents of New
Hampshire it's also visitors to New
Hampshire
um who who we are responsible for
responding to like hikers in those
situations that you mentioned
um we're constantly looking at process
Improvement we're looking at
opportunities to utilize technology to
deliver more efficient services to
improve the services that we do deliver
um and and we're leaders in the industry
the 911 system in the state of New
Hampshire it's a Statewide 911 system
which is unique there aren't many like
this in in the country we've got Cutting
Edge forensic laboratory analysis that's
being put into place to address
to address
efficiency issues that we have highly
trained law enforcement professionals
nationally certified fire training
programs comprehensive fire
investigations
community-based emergency preparedness
and planning automated fuel tax
Collections and DMV operations focused
on on customer service while also
ensuring compliance with with federal
and state law so that that concludes our
presentation and if anyone has any
additional questions we'd be happy to
address them I would just say one
comment it's working
because I read recently they were the
safest state in the nation
so yes absolutely thank you Steve
so so yeah thank you you know the the
only thing I'll add to it that isn't
here is and I think we touched in a
little is even even to keep to respond
to everything that happens that you
can't prepare for the unknown so every
day you know you can think of a
strategic plan but every day it could be
you know we don't know what's going to
happen right but we have we have some
major projects in the upcoming biennium
that Steve's got to manage buildings
facilities testing programs so we've got
a lot I'm also assigned 30 boards and
commissions that either myself or
someone from the agency sits on so above
and beyond the day to day whether you're
the division of State Police or or the
director of Motor Vehicles we've it's
good we've been forward-leaning to to
secure grant funding and to to advance
our you know our customer service but
but you know it's it it's a lot of work
and and I'll end with the people that we
have there are truly really dedicated
they are getting it done and and I
appreciate your uh your support and
thank you Mr chairman commissioner we
had some pretty good uh Federal fund
increases because of covid and so on can
you anticipate whether these will last
through this two years of this next
budget or if you give it they grants
that have lasted a while or so do we
know yeah I'll let Steve but we we were
really like anytime There's an
opportunity Steve put pen to paper where
are our gaps where can we Bridge a gap
where we might have a lack of employees
but technology will bridge that bill so
so yes we did really well so I think
you're going to start seeing the federal
opportunities decline now
um we were very strategic in ensuring
that
we applied for things that would be as
close to a one-time cost as possible and
I say as close to because whenever you
move something
um to you know an online or an
electronic function there's going to be
maintenance costs there's a tail to that
um but we're we're cognizant of that and
we're comfortable that we could absorb
that tail with operating funds and that
it was worth it and so um so technology
improvements process improvements that's
where we tried to focus
um and then the the only variance there
is going to be your your pass-through
funds to locals and so that's what I
think you're going to see carry forward
through this biennium and then
potentially drop off in the next you
know I'll speak to it to compliment
Steve and it's in his his assistant Miss
domian who's out back the the it's easy
to see a problem but they quickly looked
at the plate room and ordering plates
and stickers and decals and it was paper
and they worked many nights carrying
license plates back and forth doing
deliveries in in both Steve and 80 said
you know we need to integrate this with
with our vision we need to automate we
need to be able to strategically
understand when folks are going to need
more license plates what are the
sequence what are the decals we need to
automate that but very quickly they put
a grant together secured the funds and
but again it's not done yet now now the
work is really starting but but you know
we have we haven't been able to fix
everything but the things that I think
are the most important we've got some
federal dollars and we've had support
and and we've got the folks that can get
the projects completed
I was impressed with the way you handled
this flood of of special license plates
requests that
commissioner Flynn just said no no no
for years and years and we had all these
people I want one for the military I
want one for this group I want one for
the and and that coming out with that
plate with me your organization you sell
the sticker leave me alone well that was
very successful that was very clever
because everybody wanted their own plate
yeah and you see States like Florida I
bet they have 15 16 different license
plates I mean that gets pretty
complicated it's bad enough all the ones
you have to do for the legislature right
I remember somebody when they were
having that came in with a big case of
special license plates that everybody
had to have well thank you I appreciate
it was a challenge but you dealt with it
very well thank you
yes thank you um I had a question this
morning of Department of Transportation
and they said oh no that's safety yeah
so now that you're here so no so I will
tell you and it's important for you to
know that what we're doing here it
doesn't work if we don't support the
other state agencies right so we have a
very good relationship with um build
Cass fish and game
um all of them HHS I work very closely
with with Lori Weaver you know we have
this thing called the state hospital
that we shared together that we have a
lot going on and um you know when you
say it's one team our team but it but it
really is it's a big team yeah that this
was around
um enforcement of weight limits for
Bridges
um just in particular I had constituents
come to me to say that they know that
there are uh trucks going over the
little Newcastle Bridge there's a big
residential construction site off Wild
Rose Lane and
um these people are involved in
construction and they're pretty sure
that those trucks are way over the limit
and so they're asking me about it and so
just you know in a general sense how do
you deal with the weight enforcement I
joke about it when people ask me about
going over the bridge I say just roll
down your window you know so no so so
again I I mean I that's that's we we
several years ago we worked in this
bridge weight formula and there is there
are federal requirements but our troop
to you guys we've worked with we worked
with the industry we looked at it so
there's a couple things there's the
there's the overall weight then it's how
the load is signed it could be you know
an axle overweight but
um but many of those
um many of those are are okay what I
would do is if there if anyone has a
question I would Point them to Troop G
if they think somebody
oftentimes they're not
um and uh but again we worked through
that we worked we sat with D.O.T we sat
with FM CSA Federal Motor Carrier and we
dealt with the industry
you know we've dealt with uh the Timber
on it you know we've you know so we
listened to them and I look at the the
folks and say is this is this unsafe and
if it's not then we have to look at you
know balancing you know folks are trying
to you know transfer comments the other
thing is if you look at the States you
would think they are all like they would
be standardized but there are different
requirements Maine was different than
Vermont and New Hampshire so it's a lot
to learn you know but thankfully we have
I have a final question kind of a nosy
question
I was talking to our town man I'm from
Hampton
and I was talking about town manager
recently about Staffing and vacancies
and he did we started discussing he has
an ability to call somewhere I don't
know who he calls I I'm asking if it's
you once you understand what I'm going
to ask you
on certain nights during the summer
Hampton Beach is very close to exploding
right
and he has the ability and has exercised
two or three times per per summer and
I'll call
that he calls and and
reinforcements show up I mean he has to
pay for him pay their mileage and all
that is that through you yeah well
actually it's it's through it's actually
lower than than me so so you've got the
colonel of the State Police we have
field captains then troop a which
Hampton Falls under would have a troop
Commander or a lieutenant and and every
year they have an excellent relationship
you know uh uh Jamie Sullivan who was
the police chief
um you know he's dealt with this for
years but it's actually very very simple
you know if they think they need more we
have a contingency plan they call and we
respond some folks to help them but we
have a tremendous relationship with with
Hampton and we generally know it's that
preseason you know May and June when
kids are skipping school but then once
and you get a hot you get a hot day and
but but we prepare for that now but yeah
he works he works with uh with this with
the state police okay just nosy thing
thank you thank you appreciate it yeah